game before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell the way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos guys like
the video on your way in if you have
watched two or more of my lives and you
don't subscribe we have beef okay beef
people so make sure you hit that like
button also guys we have two clips
channel so make sure you go subscribe to
both just pearly clips and pearl daily
also I've been lighting up the Twitter
spear I haven't gone crazy on Twitter
lately go follow my Twitter pearly
things I think I'm almost a 300K on
Twitter and I dropped a video of me
rapping today so make sure you go follow
it yes okay
um so today's topic
isoflation yes but before we get into
that we're gonna do intro so everybody
do your name your age your relationship
status and a fun fact about yourself
starting here and then going around oh
gosh uh my name is Melissa Todd I'm 46
I'm married and I've been a sex worker
now for 27 years wow how's that you're
married as a sex worker is that like the
first question people ask usually when
you announce that possibly yeah yeah top
ten okay go ahead hi I'm chanella James
I'm an artist I'm 28 no 29 now not me
for getting my age but anyway um happens
to all of us yeah no you just kind of
you just start losing count
what kind of artist a musician okay like
a guitar singing I sing okay cool yeah
I'm a rapper so I get it yeah
is it funny stutter no no no no crap
girl thank you go ahead hi I'm Chantal
and I'm 20 and I'm also a student okay
what are you studying nice thing cool
I'm Rebecca I'm 30
um
what was the other two questions name
age relationship status fun fact
um I'm in a relationship fun facts um I
don't like pigeons you don't like
pigeons
sorry I do not like pigeons
go ahead yeah
this is Kevin
I'm a business entrepreneur I own
Silverback group and also
um a rap on my noise
um 32
um fun fact I speak four different
languages wow what for uh speak Dutch
um because I lived in Holland my okay my
parents live in Holland
I was brought up in Holland and I speak
tree which is my original language I'm
from Ghana originally and I speak
English
and I also speak Japanese
wow yeah that was impressive anyone
gonna ask was
just money just money for police
oh okay yeah okay right then me too
go ahead hi I'm Claire and I'm mature
I'm an actress and I am the owner of any
occasion foreign
hi yeah my name is Claire I'm mature I'm
an actress and I own a florist online
um any occasion
a forest you said a Florist a florist I
think it's a forest no no I'm a flower
why do you why do you say mature are you
embarrassed of your age no I'm not
embarrassed of my age but a lady never
gives her age away oh really I feel like
that's what people say when they're old
maybe all right go ahead it's
interrogation boss and I'm 25 and fun
fact about me is
I was born in the yellow Mercedes
do you they should give you like a
discount
no no okay
um so today's topic
whole flation yes so does anyone know
what hopeflation is
no you've never heard of this topic okay
so this is something that has been going
around online that the men have been
saying
modern men have to work five times
harder than their grandfathers did for
women 20 times worse than what their
grandmothers were it's called
hopeflation
do you guys think that's true no no I'm
extraordinary idea worse in what way
better in what way
um I would say worse in that we offer
less kids we're more promiscuous we're
fatter and
um I would just say in general most
people like a third of us didn't grow up
in two parent homes so a lot of us
weren't trained or like told how to be a
wife oh okay
well I don't think being promiscuous
makes it necessarily worse and I think
probably fewer children is a good idea
oh less kids is good yeah I think I
think so because the world's imploding
so you know the world's what about like
the replacement birth rate yeah well
again I think less is definitely better
than more okay who would fill the jobs
oh there's enough of us for that I'm
sure AI as well also of course okay the
robots will do it okay but what about
like building the buildings oh running
the infrastructure you know 45 percent
of men are in infrastructure jobs
okay I'm sure robots will help with that
okay robots
FM kids yeah all right all right there's
too many all right all right what about
you do you think that's true uh repeat
again because I'm not gonna lie okay
it's all right I got you I got you
modern men have to work five times
harder than their grandfathers did for
women 20 times worse than what their
grandmothers were
yeah I just don't I don't what even
is that like how
okay what do men want
they want a woman that supports them
okay do you think women today are more
supportive than our grandmothers
to be honest I don't know whose grandma
was what back in the day okay what about
what about what about your grandma I
know that
it all depends on the person that you
are I mean I'm gonna make one caveat for
the show I'm sorry to cut you I'm gonna
let you finish no it depends I'm Banning
it depends I'm banned it like we have to
pick a side just so we can this is a
conversation in general not for everyone
so we're just talking about the average
man average woman but sorry go ahead
um
now I've been thrown off because I'm
just thinking of a bit more of a so you
said support you said support like men
want support and I agree with you yeah
do you think women today are more
supportive than our grandmothers some of
them ain't supportive at all some of
them want everything just handed to them
okay without doing anything okay I
wasn't about to swear so then you would
you would agree with this then right
yes yeah yeah yes to a certain extent to
a certain extent to a certain extent
okay go ahead I agree you agree tell me
why
I well of course with inflation and
everything I do believe that men are
working 10 times if not 20 times harder
than our grandfathers did and definitely
as women we are offering a bit less
especially with
the lives we have today in what way do
we offer less we always want less kids
because we want a career before we even
want to answer marriage by the time we
enter marriage we don't really have the
capacity to bear as many children as the
men would like so yeah okay
um I would agree as well
with who
with the statement okay okay
um yeah because I find that women
actually want too much which is why men
have to work harder okay
how do women typically want too much
well not necessarily too much but they
want a lot more now than they wanted
back then okay what do we want today
that we didn't want yesterday
pretty much everything can we list a
couple things I'll give you one I don't
know if six foot was on the table a
hundred years ago I don't know if that's
what the the grandmothers and great
grandmothers were like you need a man
that's six foot they need to drive they
need to have the good job they need to
have the money and the expenses to be
able to afford the woman okay so I feel
that that's what a lot of women in UK
Society want do you think men do you
think men used to have to afford a woman
no you know a little bit yes but not as
much as I don't think it was asked for
as much okay as it is not you think a
woman was more willing to work with a
man yeah okay what do you think
um well I'm not sure if it's a correct
term to use whole flation and I also
feel like
it's been the same it's just more
amplifier now because we can see it like
for example if my parents or let's say
my grandparents had an issue I would
never find out now I'm finding out
things now what my granddad did after he
passed but now I think things are more
transparent if you see on social media
what happened in in L.A I think we are
sort of
easy to to to get information rather
than how I was before I think women have
been the same uh and men have also been
the same I think the only difference is
we we can see it now the problems have
been more um magnified than it was back
then
did your grandma stay with you yeah you
did of course she did Sir do do women
today stay with their husbands
um not many no so wouldn't you say it's
different I think it's different
um it's not different as in what the
perception of it my grandmother's
sustained but don't mean that she was
fully happy with the situation right but
she committed through it all but I feel
like women lately sort of feel like why
do I need to stay misery if I can just
go and
if I can just capitalize on on life
itself let's say my grandmother didn't
have that um that space or that that
world to even navigate through freely um
freely as a woman to even you know just
do things for herself so I guess she
filmed she couldn't do things first I
mean not that she couldn't it's just the
world would wouldn't allow it to
navigate through life as it is now they
wouldn't allow her to navigate yeah
through life I said this is book cover
what do you mean allow allow using for
example is a book I read I think it's
called a thousands a Thousand Candles in
the sand I'm not sure but it's to do
with something happening happening in um
Afghanistan where this woman this woman
went a lot to travel about a man being
with them so imagine just imagine coming
from that world how are we supposed to
leave your husband you can't even go to
the shop without being
um being with a male figure they want to
allow you to send back home so what was
the reason for that long I was I don't
know it's just well because the world
well the world used to be a more
dangerous place too it's a dangerous now
right but I'm saying like we have
institutions that protect women that
depending on the time period and where
you were in the world didn't always
exist like the police force like legal
system systems that could you know what
I'm saying so it was sometimes we judge
like laws of the past by the times of
today you know what I mean so I don't
know that law I was just asking it's not
I don't think it's a law I think it's
just more culturally right this is in
Afghanistan this is a book I read okay
about 1920. okay they're going to wrote
the book was actually in the story that
she was telling about I just feel like
well I just when I hear a loud like it
sounds like we couldn't work back then
and we could no it could work but I'm
just saying back to your you saying that
did my grandmother stay yeah and I'm
trying to bring it back because maybe if
she had the opportunity to go out there
and navigate us how women can today
right well no she might have no I've
stayed so it's a circumstances but I
feel like the world has always been a
bit terrifying for
for just I guess just people not knowing
how to stay together I feel like men
have been men and women have been women
but just not women didn't have the
platform to say what they're saying now
okay so you think women have always been
the same now they just leave or like now
they're it's just out in the public yes
I feel like now we can see more like
before we wouldn't know what's happening
in someone else's family but now you've
got people filming what's happening in
their own household and posting on
social media or like everyone I think
people have an opinion you've got
someone just laying in his bed at home
could you say whatever and not get to me
we're about way back I wouldn't know
what he thinks what she thinks so I'm
just stuck more a little wealth that
I've created for myself my own
perception of the world but now your
perception can be injected by anyone
someone from Dubai can say something and
I can see on Twitter and feel offended
like what was this whereby before
there's no 12 it's not social media
there's no internet just live in your
own world okay
what do you think hmm
wow I actually agree with the statement
and the reason why I agree with the
statement is because guys do
generally have to work much harder now
and the reason why I feel that they need
to work much harder is in terms of
inflation and in terms of inflation in
the last 10 years it's absolutely
ridiculous there is no chance for young
people and the government just keeps
raising inflation they say the raise
raise the wages but however the
inflation Rises just above the wages so
then a lot more has to go in for them to
get a lot out in terms of women
um do they give less
well I can't speak for every woman it
depends on how that woman thinks and
what her perspective is
remember no it depends
so again I wouldn't pigeonhole every
single female some females yeah are gold
diggers and some females are not what
what value do women in 2023 bring the
average chick
um well if you're average I'm not sure
about the average but however I was
brought up in a way where
we were
raised to support our men and to stand
beside our men so I mean they may not
have had a lot but you would support
them in their Endeavors or their dreams
Etc
um and you'd be that backbone
um towards their goals or their dreams
Etc do you think most women do that
um I can't speak for most women but for
what I've seen for the females around me
no they don't okay
so yeah especially with like half of
like how can we say we're supportive if
half of us leave
I mean I think in terms of leaving
um It's like because you know it's like
you if you're gonna support you gotta
stay and support him you know
again I know you see you don't like the
word depends but however I wouldn't
recommend for someone to stay in an
abusive relationship so if someone's
being why is it why is abusive the first
thing that comes to your head because
I'm not saying that's
yeah but I've known women that have left
from relationships because of physical
abuse is that the majority
um I can't really speak for the majority
you think the majority of men are
abusing women you think that's probable
no okay so like why is that the first
thing that comes to your head
have you seen it's about supporting
leave what I'm saying circumstances
right but I'm saying if half of women
are leaving and then the first thing you
say is abuse I'm just I'm asking why
that's the first thing
I'm saying that could be one of the
things I'm not saying that's the first
thing I'm just saying no I'm saying
that's the first thing you said though
yeah so my first thing I would say if a
relationship is abusive then you have
the right to leave okay
right but like my my point was that half
of women are leaving and so I'm saying
we can't be supportive if we're leaving
like half of us
you know what I mean
well
and unless someone knows a reason why
they're leaving every every relationship
and every partnership has their reasons
why they leave what are good reasons to
leave a marriage
wow I would say abuse okay outside of
abuse which we we agree is the minority
right
um
outside of abuse I don't know I feel
like
it really really depends or say
someone's a heavy Gambler okay gambling
gambling and abuse but you would you
agree those are minority cases not
majority yeah I guess so yeah okay okay
okay so are there any other good reasons
to leave
outside of that I would say no so
wouldn't you say the majority of women
are not supportive yeah yeah I would say
okay okay what about you hopeflation
true or false
I would partially agree with that
statement so I agree with the part where
there isn't much quality woman that I
left that has dropped massively
um
I slowly disagree with the part where
men have to work extra hard now and days
compared to the men
back in the days
um on two aspects financially is more
easier
to gain financial success if you just
understand the strategies to it in
today's timing and in terms of finding a
woman
um
I think it's absolutely easy for males
to find a decent woman only because
females are now degrading themselves and
they're showing it in front of the whole
world in the public so men are now able
to now look at that and say okay well I
don't want you that they can filter more
easily because females are just upcoming
degrading themselves what is a decent
woman
[Laughter]
at least someone would carry you such
qualities that would facilitate being a
mother a wife and a lady and some of
those will come from the parenting how
they were raised in the first place and
then part of that will also be bound to
their decisions that they make in life
do you think the majority of women were
raised to be wives no
okay what if a guy wanted 10 kids where
would he get that
Are there women that want to give 10
kids nowadays no do you know what do you
know what the average guy got
um in 1800
no for kids
per woman
but that's the thing there is quality
woman out there it's just more easier to
filter for it now right so what does a
quality woman give to a man
a quality woman is is basically a woman
that most men would dream to have or the
top woman that Grandparents were okay
okay so what what does she give
like what does she bring to the table a
quality woman
I don't I don't agree with females
bringing anything to the table no but
you said it's not that hard for a man to
find equality okay but I'm saying we
have to Define what is a quality woman I
can Define to you what type of woman
that they won't want okay but no I'm
asking what because you said a quality
I'm saying what would they want right
like how many kids does a quality woman
bring is she a virgin is she like what
like how old is she what does a quality
woman look like
okay should be well groomed okay
um she'll be well presented well spoken
um quite intelligent in that sense she
would also have the skills to know how
to
cook
and well how to use kitchen app I would
normally say to people two things a
woman should know how to
um feed the hunger and heal the sick
within the kitchen okay those are two
qualities um that woman should have what
about age
the names doesn't really hold really
much weight because you can be a quiet
woman for the rest of your life could be
50. so a 40 year old woman is equally as
quality as a 20 year old woman there can
still be quality women at just different
ages
they're probably better no who's better
you could probably even be better at
what an old age you might get a bit more
mature so what kind of experience what
what do you bring to Top 40 that you
wouldn't have at 20. a bit more of a
mature attitude are older women
generally known for being more agreeable
and better
yeah
no they are maybe you've not ever
experienced them I've only interviewed
hundreds of women it doesn't matter
there's houses millions of us there is a
lot there's a lot of things that we
haven't experienced you know that we
can't really comment okay what are what
are women over 30s reputation that are
still single good or bad
oh the reputation defines them as a
person yes oh right yeah I don't agree
yeah you don't think we can make
generalities based on a reputation
no no we can make no I know some men
that don't give a crap yeah right we're
talking about women we're talking about
women
if you think we're talking about women
all right I understand that
but why are we what is it is it is it
for the men so we're talking about this
right but I'm saying if she's 40 what is
she going to bring to a guy who wants a
new wife and a family more sexual
experience
do men do men want wives with more
sexual experience some do I think the
more interesting ones
I don't think so maybe he doesn't maybe
you or does you're more likely to get
divorced the more sexual experience you
have she's actually true yeah yeah well
maybe that's because you won't settle
for less
right but what is subtle well sadly is
when you're in a marriage that isn't
perhaps perfect and you want to go out
and explore what else is available right
that's the problem yeah because women
think they deserve more than they do
yeah
one perspective well I mean if you if
you could get it you would get it right
so if she hasn't gotten it how does she
deserve something she can't get
just has to keep looking just keep
checking
um
no but seriously a guy that wants a wife
what is he going to get out of a woman
that is 40 years old it's geriatric
pregnancy she can't bring him kids how
is that how is that equally I mean I
know you don't want kids but I think
okay I know you don't want a lot of kids
right right
even having children what are you
planning children
every day of my life yeah yeah
so so the question is what what does a
40 year old woman bring that a 20 year
old can't so men don't care about sexual
experience okay well better conversation
more life experience more money
potentially better career more do men do
men care about your career in education
I hope so yeah again the interesting
ones would I'm sure
so so the the interesting man care about
your career what what is a career to a
guy that has one it's more like the
broke men don't care the broke men care
about your career I think it'd be more
important to a man with a career because
they'd have something to talk about and
points you can relate to each other no
do you think do you really you're
nodding you think that's true no yeah
it's very true it's not true or maybe
not in your world love and
there is a lot of things going on that
you might not have experienced to really
be able to comment okay then why why do
the richest men not not care about a
woman's career why do they go for a
young attractive women what do they go
for models the more naive ones the more
why do you think they're naive there's a
lot of them that are naive some of them
don't even know what they want they just
see what's on social media what's out on
you know on the Internet or the flash
the blings give me the car give me the
clothes
give me the jewels that's what a lot of
young girls are like how is that
different from the older women the older
women are doing the same thing no but
some women grow out of it and they
realize that there's more about a man
than just his money you can be stable if
you're on the same level that's nice you
know have your money but I'm just doing
all of the extra stuff oh do you want me
to finish yeah yeah
so all the extra stuff it's been there
done that when you grow up you grow out
of it then you start more focusing on
the man's mentality their mental health
how to become better not be
a nuisance kind of become a team you
then start becoming best friends it's
not really about the jewels and all the
extra stuff like that's a young
mentality that's fine
a lot of them still end up single with
all the knowledge they have about men
and how to be better they still end up
single I don't know a boy I've got
married parents they've been together
from 20 to now and they're they're 57 so
I don't know maybe I haven't experienced
this generation I can't say I don't know
I don't know yeah why are they less
married than ever
can't say
we don't know okay
if the if if the data shows that men
don't like women the older they get what
does that mean
who's the data I think every dating app
data that you can possibly take Dayton
UPS oh
even if you if you have men um pick
women by scent they still pick the
younger women
yeah they literally don't even have to
see the women they try to keep
themselves Young no I mean there's
biological reasons why we do the things
we do and men are attracted to Purity
they're attracted to youth because
historically they had to reproduce and
you're more likely to be able to
reproduce more children with a younger
woman
but you can't just undo biology the same
way you like taller men because they can
protect you the same way you like
muscles because it can protect you the
same reason women like rich men because
they want resources men are attracted to
Purity they're attracted to youth are we
talking about men over 50 or how old are
we even talking about we're talking
about older men like younger women okay
and that's over what age all ages okay I
mean the the dating app is between 18
and 80. and you know what you know what
age they ranked the most attractive from
18 to 80 all of them 22.
I've had some apps go as long as 18 or
men or women it doesn't Peak till 50.
so really and Trudy men are just looking
for the looks
it starts with looks yeah
and everything else I know some girls
that just don't lift a finger
and they get it oh they don't even need
a personality some men like that they
thought well I think I think that's the
whole point is that like that's all
women bring in 2023 the majority of us
haven't been raised to be wives
you think that's untrue
um
this day and age anything below 25 they
have been struggling
women okay
not all of them
but
there is a lot that have been struggling
guidance wise
yeah yeah because we got I think the
women between like they're more free
spirited is that is that good for
society
both ways
both ways it's good so it's good it's
good
and it's a bit bad so it's like you
can't take I mean
ah
to be honest everyone's expectations in
it
is different but a lot of young girls
haven't been really
taught about respecting themselves you
know they don't they're not been told
how to conduct themselves but then we
all get our moments I'm not gonna say
I'm some special we've all had our
moments but I feel like it's all to do
with the maturity but I I do believe
that it works good and bad for like that
free spirit so
maybe if they want an older guy an older
man might not like that free spirit too
much because they kind of want depending
on the guy sorry I know you don't like
that word they might want a bit more of
a submissive
girl okay
you think older women are more
submissive
some
some are people more likely to change
when they're older or younger
older
until 18 is he more likely to stop if he
stops at 18 or if he stops at 35
he's been doing it for 15 years or he's
been doing it for two years they don't
stop guys guys don't ever change do you
think do you think women change
yes
I do maybe I'm just talking on my behalf
if there's others that don't then I
can't say no you don't like it's not my
it's not my place to say that but I do
know of everyone around me that they've
changed from in their early 20s to their
mid 30s you're a woman and you don't you
you
okay let's put it like this you're so
sure that guys don't change and you're
not a guy but for a woman you have a
completely different view on it how does
that compute you're so right I'm so
sorry apologies some guys
what makes a woman valuable
me
um gosh well everything I've said really
I think being helpful uh okay how
respectful of men I'll go along with
that
um
and having their own Ambitions as well
and being able to make their own money
okay money being helpful okay
go ahead what makes a woman valuable
hmm why do I feel like I'm going to
repeat myself
to repeat myself okay um
right
judging on male friends of mine what
they've said what they find is valuable
in a woman
is the biggest word is to stay and ride
with them
okay which is yeah it's a loyalty thing
even though a lot of women
wouldn't agree with it
is something that men tend to really
love is a loyalty thing they want to
know that that woman is just you they
want to know that that woman is the only
one
you're the only one as a man that's
going with this woman basically I'm not
going to go into too much details
that is something that I've heard from a
lot of men that they do like the Loyalty
obviously you know the same old
cook and all that kind of stuff but then
again I've also heard which I kind of
understand to a certain extent that when
you're doing all that wifey wifey stuff
it's great they know that you're home
but it gets boring
for some men
that's why some men go and cheat because
they want someone that's not doing the
everyday stuff that is going on at home
I don't agree with it but
it's just something
that I have
basically
heard of and it's a lot a lot of men say
that okay that they want to cheat no
that it's just like it's boring you know
with all these these things that we as
women feel that is valuable to a man we
we think what we think but men won't
think the way we think you know well you
know why it gets boring for them if you
ever heard the phras you can't compete
with Noob you know
it's because men crave sexual Variety in
order to pass on their genes they had to
you know had a Genghis Khan like get two
out of every 100 people you like screwed
everybody that's the best way to
procreate
the same reason it's the same reason we
like Rich guys right because if you got
the highest value guy who is the most
likely to protect you and pass on
resources to you there's biological
reasons we feel the way we feel but you
know he had a queen and a concubine
so we should we shouldn't confuse what
he does with the concubine with the
queen
right would you agree with that or
disagree no I understand what yeah yeah
um what about you
um Purity loyalty respect and a caring
nature okay
that I would have added to it oh I don't
know if there's anything that I could
add to what she said I would have said
the exact same thing okay
I will say more rules I think if she got
good morals then she would take all the
boxes that one saying so if you've got
good morals didn't she she'll be
respectful and um that would just
naturally
reciprocate and then at least do loyalty
for respect that I gave you'll be loyal
okay
I think a woman should be a man's peace
and a good home
okay how does a woman become a man's
piece
by not stressing him out
supporting
supporting him
um with what he chooses to do
um and yeah make the home a home
what's the best way she cannot stress
them out
bye giving him problems
um or telling him problems that he
doesn't really need to okay know about
it Etc
okay
um I can give you three points of what
would make a woman valuable today okay
those three points would be uh Health
but they're healthy okay no children
and the third point would be
um that's hard
I'll say this contributes but a
two-parent household that they've
experienced lived in okay
so question when do you yourself I know
some of I know you said you already have
kids
um if you want more kids when would you
want them
then remind them what age you are and
what age you'd want kids I was 24 when I
had my son I think that's probably about
right and it is true you know we're all
just bags of chemicals and the older you
get egg quality drops off and you do get
more disabilities possibly and um yeah
certainly nature intended us to
reproduce teens and early 20s okay
when do I want kids
um remind them how old you are and what
age you want kids I'm 29. okay
um to be honest I've been kind of
thinking about children but I just feel
like
when I'm a little bit more
stable when I finish doing certain
things with myself then I'll I'll have
them I can actually have and I've got a
partner okay well I've just put it on
hold for a sec not for too long low key
maybe next year but okay I need to go
and travel what are you okay so you want
you want to travel want to travel a bit
get there I'm just curious like why like
when I grew up I traveled with my family
yeah like why do we have to travel first
and then have the family
oh no I don't eat I like that idea as
well yeah I just feel like I need to do
some things by myself separately
and then I'll get to the family well I
just don't I just don't understand that
mindset do you know what I mean it's
like because you can do both yeah you
can go on a trip with your kid yeah no
it's harder but you know
um so I'm just curious like what made
you say you have to do that first
something I want okay just it's just me
I just want to travel without a kid
first and then and then yeah
um I'm 20 and I'm hoping to have
children by like between 23 and 25. okay
yeah
um I'm 30. I already have a son
um I don't know did you say 30 wow you
do not look that old yeah I'm 30. um I
already have a son
um and how old are ruin you had your son
my son is six so I was 24. okay
um
I don't mind having more children I
think I give myself to 35. okay and then
you know I I don't think I don't see
myself wanting to have kids off the
paper you don't mind having more kids or
you want more kids I don't mind it's not
something that I want well I'm in a
relationship so if it's something you'll
have them then yeah okay so but um well
I'm just asking what you want and your
perfect reality are you done or you want
more it is is up in the air okay it's
like one day you think yes the next day
you think no
not necessarily it's just it's an open
okay open for okay all right
um I'm thinking around like 35 so I've
got like two three years to go okay yeah
I mean if it happens then it happens
okay
well I feel like when you have your kids
that's down to your personal choice of
what age you have done so long as you
can provide for them and love them and
give them the things that they need and
you've got the support Maybe by Family
their family Etc
um in terms of age I feel that that's
very personal there isn't a right age or
a wrong age
um maybe in terms of when you said that
old woman yes there is more health risks
um I didn't say right or wrong I said
what age do you want to have kids
um
or age even even if you passed it like
what would be the ideal age to have kids
well personally speaking I feel that
being a younger parent is more Advantage
um simply because you can raise them and
grow with them you're still got a lot of
energy where you can do quite a lot of
activities with them
um when you're a more mature parent I
feel that you become less energetic and
it may become a bit harder not
impossible but however it's not going to
be as easier when you've got like a lot
of energy when you're young
okay so what age
I would say
20s maybe okay like 20 or 29 25. I would
say 20 going on 21 22 27 20 so early 20s
early 30 20s yeah okay and do you have
kids
um yeah I do okay how was that around
the age you had them
um no I've had them a bit younger which
I'm glad that I did okay
um why is that you just said more energy
that's what you're saying
um because it's facts I've had children
and when I was younger had a way a lot
more energy whereas becoming a more
mature parent I would have a way lot and
less energy now than what I did yeah now
I've heard that that if you wait too
long like like this is my dad my
youngest sister is 10 years younger than
me and he's just exhausted he's like I'm
trying to get these kids out of the
house
um what about you I'm 25 and if I had a
partner I would have children as soon as
he's ready to be able to cater
I'll marry you in the next six months
immediately yeah okay
um
what are your deal breakers
Men smell funny or if they're stupid or
boring I guess
um if they're jealous and possessive
um
obviously abusive that kind of thing
why is why is abusive it's not just you
guys it's everybody abusive yeah it's
like why is that the first thing women
say I guess it's like the worst thing
you can imagine really yeah but it's
like why are we why are we always
thinking of the worst thing that could
happen
books and debate I suppose you go to the
extreme to make a point
you know all right just men that smell
funny then and bore me okay abusive and
see it's like not but it's true though
come on who you ask the question it's
very obvious No One's Gonna Stay with
that abusive crazy psycho that's beating
you left right and tonight my question
is not telling you to stay with an
abusive guy it is why is that the first
thing that we bring up if we can agree
it's like why why is that why do we
always go to the extreme like the worst
thing that could happen maybe because
it's just out there you know you hear of
it often
in it that wouldn't be your deal breaker
though What's your deal breaker mine
mine yeah
yeah boy because if I was to get into it
with my my partner then we was to start
getting mad like probably be mad back
you know women are more but you know
women are more violent than men
yeah I've seen some stuff no so it's
it's funny because one-sided abuse women
hit men one-sided more than men hit
women one-sided yet women are always the
ones that bring up abuse when if we're
gonna be technical about it men should
be the ones bringing up abuse and they
never do yeah but why maybe we're not
abusive maybe we can say it maybe men
that haven't been abusive can say it too
like maybe when you're just not when
you're not abusive Matt probably will
bring it up because it's something that
you just don't believe in you know no my
my whole point is women have this like
negative picture of men that they're
just abusive out to get us well all of
them I I would say I would say in
general I hear the word abuse come up
way too often considering like from
women I never hear it from men even
though one-sided abuse is more common
from women to men but that's because the
men are meant to be Alpha and the
stronger one so they would never admit
that anyway
my my point is like why do women always
go to the extreme
if if we would agree right we'd agree
it's the minority of guys that are
abusing women well we would agree that's
not a majority
right that's how you're right right like
this shouldn't be you think over 50 of
men are abusing women
I wouldn't say it's the majority but
with my friends and stuff and family and
stuff I've seen it quite a lot and from
what I've heard it's something that I
personally wouldn't never want to go
through and so I'm not saying it's the
majority of men but I have heard the
quite frequently from lots of different
backgrounds I meet randoms and tell me
yeah it's lies what's lies sorry what's
lies the the abuse allegations they're
they're mostly lies wait I don't get it
yeah women lie about abuse yes no yeah
obviously
I would say the majority of women they
were there they were abused are lying
okay because what they did was they
expanded the definition of abuse so
women will use these words that like
mean nothing like like they like for
example
um what what is coercion
and I've and the only reason I say this
is because I've done these shows so many
times and women come on they tell me
their story and then I ask questions and
it's not abuse I'll give you an example
um had a girl come on she said my
ex-boyfriend like shoved me out of the
house or whatever like pushed me out and
I was like okay like why did he shove
you like out to the ground or whatever
turns out she refused to leave his house
she was trespassing
I mean I think if I have someone that is
breaking and entering into my house I
certainly can shove you out of there but
yeah they're not meant to be together
and what kind of shove because um if you
love someone I wouldn't really be well
I'll tell you I'll tell you yes I'll
tell you I'll tell you the problem is I
like I know guys that have slammed a
door that the woman was holding on to
the door boom abuse and he's actually
was charged with that okay and I get
that and I'm saying and I'm telling you
you wouldn't know not being in it how
one-sided it is it's very very one-sided
like it's very much like and and the
reason we can look at this is because
um Family Court is based on a balance of
probabilities where Criminal Court is
based off of evidence so if you really
want to see how how common is abuse the
majority of abuse allegations that
happen in Family Court only 10 take it
to the police
foreign
so that tells us that the majority
aren't even taking it to the police
yeah that's why I think they're lying
the majority but would you not think
that if it's if it's to do with family
then the reason is it's not a higher
rate is because they don't want to break
up that family well if they're going to
court they're already breaking up the
family so they clearly don't give a
but there's still ways around it what
ways are there around there's still ways
around it where the father can still see
the Sun or the the daughter whatever it
is like the child but without actually
putting them in jail why would you want
to leave an abusive man out to abuse
another woman
what what no I'm serious if he was
hitting in a because I have two
questions the average man can beat up a
woman pretty easy if you're fine uh
if you don't have any visible no arms
are broken no nothing my question is how
is he abusing you what is abuse
oh there's all different type kinds of
terms of abuse correct mental abuse okay
okay right there right there right there
mental abuse mental abuse who is more
emotionally manipulative men or women
women so why are the women always crying
abuse like this is what I'm saying like
and that's the problem you said
emotional abuse that used to not even
exist that term didn't even exist until
like the 80s 70s or 80s they they got
into the feminist got into the legal
system added all these words that don't
mean anything to convince women that
were victims like they expanded the
definition of abuse
uh
and so that that's what I mean like I I
don't think it's that common for a man
to beat a woman
I would add to that and say I don't
think most females are lying I would say
they provoke the situation and they just
don't want to admit that they even
started it first or literally just
provoked it I would agree with that yeah
I just want to say for everyone who's
watching this if you're going through
your abuse right now and you you know
you find our stuff our conversation
offensive please you know this is just
our individual opinions
and if you are going through it you know
seek help and my love to you anyway
sorry I agree sorry I had to cut that
yeah I still I totally agree I still
think the majority are lying yeah I
would say over I would say 80 lying and
I think they over exaggerate it I think
they don't talk about their part to play
I think they emotionally abuse the men
oftentimes they just snap because they
emotionally abuse it I and I think it's
funny because again women do it to men
more than men do it to women yet women
are always what whining I can agree with
you
I agree with you trust me but I'm
telling you there's
some people out there right now that are
suffering and they're not they're not
they don't even know how to speak abuse
abuse totally exists mentally abusive
I'm not saying them you know I'm not
saying it doesn't exist but my whole
point is like why wouldn't you go to the
police and I and I think and no I think
we gotta end the snare I think they love
it is
I think as a woman you cannot accuse a
man of being abusive without going to
criminal court but then it's the same
thing that you said it comes down to
evidence
any guy in here any guy in here if he
abused me you don't think there would be
evidence
oh come on again
I don't think about it think about it
I'm strong wait I I deadlift I deadlift
300 pounds I can bench a plate I'm six
foot I'm tall and strong for a chick any
one of these guys could beat me up
pretty easy to the point they're like
there would be bruises there would be
there would absolutely be evidence
yeah
but I I agree with what's your name
again sorry me yeah chanela I agree with
chanella and again like I said you can't
pigeonhole every situation yeah
remember what I said before I'm talking
about in general yeah so I'm not saying
you are pigeonholing because like what
you're saying yeah you are right there
are some very manipulative women out
there and when they can't get the one
yeah the maytal lies but then on the
other hand which they're always overhand
there's generally women that are being
literally abused
yeah abuse of women exist yeah I'm not
saying they don't I mean you know young
and young I mean there is and I feel
like eat guys as well you know like I
feel like guys don't speak as much
because simply the fact that it takes
away their male masculinity and stuff
like that and it will make it I think
I'm not a man because nobody would care
they would still paint the women I I've
seen videos on Tick Tock of a woman like
freaking out at a man and what what does
everyone say in the comments well what
did he do
right I mean we had we had on uh we had
anyone country fan country fan Carrie
Underwood I dug my key into the side I
was pretty lit you know the song right
she she Keys his car for cheating and if
a guy did that to a woman everyone be
freaking out
I would even argue that if we were to
use the same
way that women Define abuse
to like look at all the cases that men
go through I would argue that almost
every woman has abused a man that
they've been a relationship with
if we were to go by the same standards
of the way women shout abuse I would say
every single woman that has dated a man
has abused that man
yeah I agree
that just got a little late on me the
drink kind of delayed a little bit
oh he was saying that most women if we
use the same definitions most women have
abused men okay
well I know someone really close to me
that um is a man that has been abused by
a woman
the word is just dramatic but anyway
either way is some sort of abuse
physical abuse I'm saying oh if we're to
use the definitions of the way
women claim abuse let's even take it out
of in general I would say you sitting
right there have abused almost every man
you've been in a relationship with Wow
awesome wait are you telling me that I
have yeah oh really is that how I come
across it's not about what you come
across I'm just telling you how
relationships go oh you so you're not
telling me that I am abusive to a man
he's saying by the definition that
feminists use okay and by the legal so
coercive control emotionally
manipulative narcissist it's like women
throw narcissist at men 24 7 when it's
like who's more narcissistic we're the
ones addicted to social media
we're all just basically corrupt aren't
we yeah that's the whole point no one's
special and no one's perfect
that she gets it wow
um okay we're we're here's your turn god
um someone who smokes just because
um that's a good deal breaker yeah yeah
this makes me nauseous
um someone who's not Christian and
someone who has a temper okay what about
he's perfect bye bye he's he's barely
been to church
I think that's the topic for discussion
I'm just curious you personally
probably not no no have you ever dated a
non-Christian before
no okay
uh what about you
um a Dale break
um
mine would be
um aggressive if they come across quite
aggressive
um if they can't communicate
um
addiction Etc okay yeah okay go ahead
um I would say um lack of self-respect
and also oh this might come across a bit
obviously but high body count I think a
woman has got like excessive sexual past
kind of hard to
psychologically to I mean if she tells
me if I don't know then I don't know but
if she if I know do you think you can
generally tell when a woman woman has a
high body count I don't think so no you
don't think you can tell I mean by just
looking at her no just by by dating her
how high is too high for you uh so it's
a bit kind of I don't know I just wanna
I wanna I wanna
pin you down but what depends how it
depends how old she is okay let's do 25
30. let's do 25 oh no let's do 20 25 and
30. 20 yeah I think 20 probably like for
like two okay two at twenty two high all
right not too high to what 20 I could
deal with that's like four five twenties
like okay okay now 25 25 it's like
eight nine okay eight or nine too much
all right 30.
okay prefer y'all could probably the
same for 25 should you should have been
in a serious relationship for at least
two three years or something like you
should have just stayed with someone for
a while well you know that's the most
common answer I get is 10.
like roughly 10 right that's yeah that's
the most common answer I get from you
guys it's funny though I feel like the
same way like all right women will give
me a number for income but they really
mean like 20 less I feel like when men
say 10 they really mean 15.
if she's hot enough I mean it's even
about that with me it's just I feel like
women with high bloody count kind of
like because I'm a guy and I'm thinking
even if me as a man fight so many
flashbacks got deal with how did you
even like even if a fan even if you
found a person before you like your soul
mate you've still got to deal with all
the sexual encounters you've actually
been through all the experiences right
order all the so bonding all the
connection you've had with so many
different people how'd you then sit just
sit with one person yet you can you
could be with them because you like them
but there's still so many things
dragging around that's okay question she
slept with three men
but one is Drake
I really don't care about that and then
okay the guy doesn't matter yeah it
doesn't really matter okay so if he was
a loser or the best guy ever I mean I
think uh rather Drake because to me
that's like oh
oh okay yeah I feel like yeah so the
celebrities would be like a better
yeah I mean well I mean yeah someone is
I feel like okay cool like hey you shoot
like okay you're short rather than some
guy thinking you didn't have any cell
value like okay do you agree with that
with what with his opinion like you know
of which part like of the you know
sleeping with Drake it's like they don't
care about all that do you feel like
that's a problem I uh I don't know the
type of gal that's gonna sleep with Dre
is like I mean yeah
she slept with three guys one of them is
straight yeah for me I mean I think most
guys will take three though that's like
damn near assume you're a virgin
nowadays so it's okay yeah no I didn't
say okay actually I think it depends on
on what relationship you had with Drake
though
the point is like if she's a girl that's
ever slept with a guy for money or clout
or any of that crap it doesn't matter if
he's Drake or if he's like Uncle down
the road
yeah but I'm saying this if she is 30
well let's say 25 and the body count is
free and one of them guys for Drake
personally I would not trip about that
yeah I get I get what you're saying but
I'm saying I'm not even going to ask her
I'm saying I'm saying if she was the
type of girl that was like a groupie
bruh okay but if he's a groupie then I'm
sure her body count will be higher
because Drake's not the only celebrity
so that means you to smash summons so
many other celebrities as well so I
guess to me the body count is what I'm
looking at life is free and Drake's in
there Papa Jake probably saw that dream
she'll probably just no I'm saying like
oh yeah it's Drake and yeah Melissa
don't know who Drake is see that's how
you know
no it's good it's good you're setting an
example not everyone is in the life that
everyone thinks that everyone's in does
this make you yeah
she's a sex worker that's literally
no it isn't like she don't know who
Drake is
most guys sex worker but doesn't know
who Drake it like yeah
um okay so deal breakers for you
foreign
I think someone who's not very educated
I don't really like people that are not
medium so a plumber
um high school diploma plumber
um
in terms of career I'm not really
bothered as long as you're like no you
said you said educated so I'm saying
high school diploma but plumber
um yeah I I would say all right then to
correct what I'm saying then someone who
you can't communicate
okay
yeah like someone who has literally no
Communications girls okay
is that it any other jailbreakers
so he communicates and you're good
that's it yeah because if you can
communicate then you can write problems
out so it's 300 pounds 5'4 but he can't
communicate
um
I'm just asking like what are your deal
breakers so if he's obese deal breaker
yes or no oh yeah that'd be a deal right
okay deal breaker if he's obese what
else
um
aggressive
what's with that okay you guys just said
you just changed abusive too aggressive
I didn't call you out I let you go when
it was aimed at me like
you bowl it's like why abuse it you on
the men's side didn't it I'm not on any
one side I'm on reality's side like that
that's the side I'm on
um okay so no obese how much money
um
I don't know just as long as you can
like feed yourself clothe yourself run a
house
um get the necessities
Etc like oh no I'm not really that
hooked up in money okay 20
000 pounds
it's average yes or no 20 000 pounds
would you date
yeah okay okay so 15 000 pounds would
you date
I'm not gonna really like date a guy
because of what he's got because I can
look after myself but but we all agree
there's there's a number that's too low
like 12 like 10 pounds an hour are you
dating
what if that's all the job that he can
do and he gets tympan and now at least
he's trying like why not come on that's
trying some guys that's probably their
own job that you can get
valuable oh
okay if that's what you want to date I'm
just asking I'm not saying that's a guy
would date what if there's guys out
there like that are trying to do
something but we're not we're not
talking about the exception we're
talking about the rule so I'm asking on
average it's not really desirable though
is it really it's not desirable I'm not
shaming anyone for wanting a man with a
job I think we should pursue men with
jobs I'm trying to figure out what your
floor is
I'm not really bothered about what a guy
earned okay but I need a number from you
jobless
so unemployed there's a homeless shelter
down the street are you dating them
clearly not okay okay right so what
what's the minimum
why is it so hard to answer these
questions I'll be very interesting
Theory I actually think women really
don't care about money like in the way
that a lot of men think the reality is
women just care about shiny things so if
a man is able to present that facade of
oh I have shiny things I can do this I
can do that
women will go for it and they really
don't understand the concept of okay
money here and you need to use it to do
this when it comes to men obviously when
it comes to them and buying their things
they understand money but when it comes
to men
it's all about the shiny things oh it's
a greater I think women just want
security not a shiny things maybe the
shiny things might symbolize that okay
he has money but what the one actually
is
I'm talking about what they actually
respond to In Real Life
Look A wise man once said Don't listen
to what women say what they do so if the
woman can come and tell you oh yeah I
love this bruv watch what she does I get
what you're saying now I'll get what
you're saying what I'm saying is in a
nutshell it's not the flash of things
that you're attracted to it's just the
skew to the thing that flashy things may
bring that's that's what I'm trying to
get exactly because I've met some women
who actually don't like guys who are
flashy who they think are disgusting
loud so what about those women they they
look at guys with all this what are we
talking about the role or the exception
I'm just just answering this question no
but you're bringing up the example even
even I would argue that even the guys
that you claim are not flashy they are
still flashing the ways women would
respond to in terms of like their status
yeah but it's not shiny it is shiny
status is a shiny thing bro how many
people have status it's bright in the
eyes of women I mean I get what you're
saying now I think the word shiny kind
of took me away but you just mean like
just credible I mean I'm a philosopher
at the end of the day
yeah I got what you're saying but I
still feel like women are attracted to
security it's just like you said it's
just in their biological nature yeah to
draw to these things yeah
um all right then direct is to the point
then I would say like if you're gonna
have a household
um at least 25k because that's what it
takes to get to run a house okay thank
you go ahead what are your deal breakers
uh my
the deal breaker is uh not passing my
interrogation process
okay oh that's what you you have you
wanted to do an interrogation show
didn't you yes okay what's your
interrogation process
um so
there's a series of five questions I
have my personal five questions that I
asked to actually use in my own day in
life
my five questions are
the first one is do you drive it sounds
very basic but yeah do you drive
um do you have any past traumas and if
so and what are you doing to resolve
them
how many baby mothers do you have
well guys are you going on dates
is the problem that we run into multiple
baby moms yes oh yeah okay yeah a lot of
some guys say they have children yeah
okay okay how many baby moms is too many
well that's a trick question you see
because if they actually say they have a
baby mother then I know what time of day
is if they don't respond to
the question is my child's mother then I
understand what the dynamic in the
situation is so that's actually a trick
question that one though okay okay but
I'd like to hear zero
would you would you deal with one
I would have to compromise that I'll be
compromising okay two no no okay so what
other questions do you ask
how many students of income
and so if he says he's a plumber
no other his one stream of income
is that okay
we could do bus driver I just pick a
train this drivers are making a lot of
money
that's what I'm asking no they all I'll
do all the trades I mean my questions
are not wrong right it's just for me to
understand the individual and if you set
free then I know I have a bonus there if
you say zero I know I have a problem but
if he says one or two then I just
understand his uh work effort and where
he would like to go the last question
that I normally ask is what is a mouse
purpose in four words and these
questions it sounds very military as I'm
saying it but I slide in the
conversation it's the way how I do it
okay but if they failed those those five
questions yeah door breaker okay so I'm
just curious one stream of income deal
breaker or no
and the trauma you think men want to be
questioned about their like past trauma
somebody respond to the question
actually okay so what's all right ask
ask him hear your questions I want to
see if he passes or not are you ready
so um do you have any post traumas and
if so what are you doing to is open
um yeah I've been to therapy actually
um yeah and that helped me a lot it was
um because I was raised by my
grandparents and kind of not like being
raised by my mom kind of had a little
like you know but now me and my mom are
cool like me and Mom are like best
friends speak to my mom like every day
and it's just being very
brought a lot of healing to me so yeah
it's been good and actually I will urge
every guy out there to if you've got any
sort of
you know disruption with your parents
whether your father or Mom just deal
with it because yeah
you have to and they they're here we're
gonna you just have to deal with it and
love them and receive the love that they
give you because it gives you a lot of
healing yeah
thank you for answering was that a good
answer the way how we answered gave me a
lot of information about him just then
and there and it also let me know that
he actually did see he has he has a past
trauma and he actually does something to
resolve it I'm more for the end result
and the fact that he actually did
something rather than sit down and feel
safe for himself he passed the question
yeah ask another one I wanna I wanna see
how we do this
I want to see you keep going and this is
fun
um okay what is a mouse per person four
words I think it's to provide protect
and
to provide protect and also to
live out his Divine Purpose that's
that's so protect provide bear children
so reproduce
earned to live his dream so whatever
gift that you know God has given you and
you have to make sure that you manifest
that in life before you die before you
leave this planet so live his dreams in
one word what does that mean
um to give out wherever to give our to
live to live out his gifts whatever gift
that he's got is to bring it into
fruition just yeah so if you can put
that in one word what would that one
to be alive
the last three words
fulfillment
yes that's it can I date you yourself
are you two gonna get together now
yeah that's it oh they've gone shy
what did you think of that answer no he
missed 50
what was wrong with the answer uh
is uh definitely uh the two words
um again like I said there isn't any
wrong or right answers but the four
words that I'm looking for is protects
provide hunt and Lead
[Laughter]
we live in London
wait you're actually not the first girl
that's come on the show and said she
wants a guy to like kill an animal but
I'm like we live in London
like where is he gonna go hunting I mean
on in time zone do you pick berries but
modern daily obviously we don't do
hunting yeah living in like you said
London 21st century so a man's hunting
now is going to Sainsbury's and buying
the food or providing the money to buy
the food
yeah exactly yeah but that that's what
men have to what I'm saying is from um I
don't know her name but anyway like she
said hunting but that's what she kind of
means but obviously you can't go and
shoot a deer or whatever so you have to
go Sainsbury's and buy steak I want to
hear I want to hear from the guys what
these questions do you would these be
like a red flag or a green flag massive
red flag bro really personally I feel
like she's in a mission I feel like
she's looking for love like she's she's
here like which is a good thing but then
if I'm not really on that kind of vibe
then you're trying oh just like okay why
do you say it's a red flag King
because when it comes to like
relationships the same way women expect
men to be tucked be tactful about how
they approach them how they ask them
certain questions I expect a woman of
intelligence to do the same thing you
can't just be asking me direct questions
as if we're like in an interrogation
doesn't make any sense yeah but she said
she doesn't do it like how she yeah bad
questions last week on a two-hour
conversation you won't even realize I'm
asking you these questions for that
purpose
what I'm saying is if you deliver it
exactly the way you delivered it it's
not is of course that won't be genuine
and anyone would assume they're not even
answer that to be honest of course
so I have a question what is the role of
a wife
but you'll say it's to bad children
uh no that's not what I would say Okay
um well to be supportive I think and
encouraging and kind and respectful and
give men a lot of what they need as long
as it isn't insane and ridiculous but I
think I work as a Dominatrix and I think
too often wives fail to do that and Men
come to me for things that women should
often be providing themselves Yeah
question actually
um because I have a theory I'm like what
can we learn from sex workers and I
think one thing I've always heard from
sex workers is a lot of times men seek
out sex workers because their wives are
not sleeping with them is that true
um yes I'm sure that's true or just
listening to them actually or just
respecting them I had a man recently
paid me to so he could cry in my arms
because their son had just died and his
wife just wasn't providing any emotional
support or um no they just really want
their wives to wear stockings and I
don't think that's really unreasonable
um yeah
um I don't sleep with men so I'm not
entirely confident on that um so yeah
how does that work with your husband he
doesn't mind no he thinks it's just
ridiculous and fun yeah he just hears
the beating noises now she's off again
who doesn't think spanking's sexiest but
you don't you don't do anything sexually
with them
no just beat them
no women that do have sex with them I
tipped actually no just no it just stops
it's just you kind of live in your own
little world yeah yeah okay
um what is the role of a wife I'm not
married so does my opinion really count
it still counts I'm just I mean the
question is does the average chick know
the role of a wife okay
um
wow
my mom she cooks she cleans
she loves she supports
she fends for her kids she
goes with
her instincts womanly instincts I don't
know if everyone's got them but she is
amazing and
my dad is still there
still there supporting
her and she's still there supporting him
so what I've seen her do
over all these years because there was
together well from before I was born
they're in their 50s now
her just
even the business they've opened up a
business they've got teamwork now
it's just it's all about building she's
built with her partner and her partner
my dad she's built him together and
she's built him yeah like together like
just they build each other okay and it's
like it's a team thing you know do you
think they're equals
equals in marriage are they equal
yes yeah yeah yeah
but
it's my you think your role in marriage
is to be an equal a teammate well I just
feel like Steph's still been right
they're happy they've been going on this
is just what I've seen obviously I'm not
going to go into my deep detail of my
life and my family but this is just my
opinion I'm not married I've just seen
what she's done and as a wife
they're still happy boy still together
still riding it and that's just me
anyway okay what is the role of a wife
to be the husband's helper to love
respect and to submit to him like he is
the leader
um and to just nurture the home make a
home okay yeah
um yeah I would say to love and um
support
um be respectful and
um to listen
and yeah I think
pretty much
and yeah be able to just give him
what he won't be looking for in other
women for
okay
I would say exactly what she said
actually but that's kind of biblical
um well but she said I agree with her
things that she's the lady over there I
don't really know her name what's your
name no no
okay what do you think what is the role
of a wife yeah I totally agree with that
to you guys
um yeah it's definitely you know to be a
helper
um to respect you know
um commit in terms of
like 10 year old as a wife
okay
okay so um that would be to nurture to
reproduce two other elements I'll say to
heal the sick and to feed the hunger
and to
contribute towards
the Legacy that the man's trying to
obtain on maintain
should you obey your husband Point Blank
period
no
no no no no no what about you
can we Define a bay I was about to say
that as well independent obey oh you
don't know what obey I mean I can get
the definition you don't you you can't
infer what it means
I'll get it I'll get you guys you mean
just say yes to everything they say
basically like the yes girl yes yeah
submit to the authority of someone or
comply with
should you obey your husband Point Blank
period
so you say no what do you say
no no okay what do you think yes yes
she's torn I see it I am she's like I
wanna I know that I know the right
answer but I don't want to say it yeah I
think it's a bit of both I think there's
certain things you should just
completely agree with and other things
that you just that is
because really and Trudy I agree with
you there's certain things yes but you
will say no to something so that is a no
you won't always obey okay
he himself
um moves with guided principles the new
issue with babies me personally I would
be God alone so if he must have got the
principles then here I think you should
bake us and we'll lead you both into an
unselfish route we both can then um
let's reap the benefits of that so yeah
he's got Godly principles and yeah you
should be
um I agree with the last bit what he
just said
and I believe yes so long as it's not
detrimental to the home
okay
I would say if it's beneficial to both
parties yes
how do you determine what's beneficial
to both parties
when your boss asks you to do something
do you say if it's beneficial to both
parties
to a boss it will be beneficial to do it
because if not you'd be fired then you
have to look at the consequences of
being fired or having the consequences
of you having a rocky relationship with
your boss now saying that you don't want
to comply so why will women submit to a
boss but not their husband because
that's not what you're not getting paid
that's different I mean if you want it
do you want a guy that provides
true when you think of it like that yeah
so like my question is why will we
submit to a boss but we have to say oh
well what's in it for me when it's her
husband work is work we shouldn't be at
home thinking that this is work now
right but it's the same Dynamic it's an
authority Dynamic right
I mean it depends what you believe
marriage is like because you seem to
have more of an egalitarian model of
marriage which is really common where
it's like 50 50 we have an equal say I I
don't believe in that like I think that
you should listen to the man is that you
you have you got a partner
no
um but I I just think you can look at
what works in history and it's literally
like the egalitarian model has never
worked
do you care to elaborate on that a bit
all right let's let's look at so
basically feminism when did it start
like the early
1900s and and that's when you start
seeing in the media that men are abusers
you start seeing these propaganda
campaigns where it's like we're 50 50.
we both have an equal say right and so
it's it's like the the further the more
closer it's been to an egalitarian model
it then the less from a submissive like
Authority structure the more divorce
rates have gone up the less children
we've had the less relationships have
formed
that's related I mean yeah because I
think today what we have it's not
marriage you know it's it's like
basically being a relationship I I think
divorce should be illegal yeah yeah
I didn't I don't think I think once
you're married that's it
yeah unless it's again the whole abuse
word then I don't think there's anything
even with cheat and I think that can be
worked out wow based very based I do
feel like I love my husband and that's
who you've married I think it'll work it
out I mean I think women cheat every day
yeah I mean women women are the biggest
cheaters in 2023 how many women we see
have ass pictures on Instagram being in
happy healthy relationships women yes is
that cheating for you yes yes I think
that is absolutely cheating what do you
need to post a picture of your butt on
Instagram for when you have a husband
what kind of Butler you know just uh
I agree I think a selfie is cheating
crazy really what do they need to see
your beauty for you got a man we're
gonna be walking on the roads everyone's
gonna see the faces what do you I mean
yeah outside but like what are you
posting it online
Also let's talk about let's talk about
women it's like we're like oh cheating
is the worst thing that could ever
happen to us well I mean are you a
virgin on your wedding day no so it's
like maybe we should get off our high
horses It's Like a Man Cheats once 50 to
70 percent of the time it's a one-time
thing so meaning he'll never do it again
most guys don't really get offered like
that so then the women are like oh
cheating is the worst thing ever like
when men are programmed to just screw
random chicks so you almost come on
you're in random chicks no no look look
I mean I don't I don't wish to be
cheated on I do not want to be cheated
on I I think that it's silly to throw
away a marriage when you have children
for your own personal feelings because I
think once you have a child it's not
about you anymore yeah but one cheat I
get that everyone no one is perfect I'm
not saying I'll be happy with it you're
gonna ride because there's kids involved
what if it's consistent okay
how did women how did women reproduce
historically
we got the attention of high value men
right the highest the the best guy in
the tribe we'd pull up our skirts and be
like look take me in right right that's
how we survived how did women or how did
men survive they'd become big get
resources right they get get strong and
what would they do
they would screw a bunch of chicks
that's how they survived so I think that
Sexes to men like attention is to women
that that's my belief and I think if
we're going to go off this logic we've
never cheated we none of us have flirted
with another guy in a relationship
neither none of us have posted a
provocative picture we're all virgins on
our wedding days I just think like maybe
we should come with a little bit of
humility that it's not like the end of
the world if he sleeps with another
person and it can be worked through yeah
my wife is consistently wouldn't you
feel a bit upset what about all that
loyalty that you've given that man that
love that energy and the neighbors
someone else why did you do that before
marriage
what are you supposed to be okay did you
want to be married dude most women want
to be married yes did we know that on
our wedding night we were supposed to be
virgins most people knew that and none
of most of us are not and that's my
point it's not it's not to say it's okay
but it's like where is the humility yeah
but you gotta throw all that virgin talk
in the bin right now we need to get back
to the fact that when you're married are
you saying it's all right to just
completely keep getting consistently
cheated on without you feeling affected
by it you know wait hold on I wanted I
had to answer that because I'm not
asking questions for no reason now
wouldn't you feel a little bit upset
like he's been here
because I was just saying something I
wanted to know whether you feel like
that's a little bit sorry am I getting
caught oh look it's not it's not the
valid point it's that my producer was
talking first
I know but she's allowed to dance
about it
a man that is going to be cheating on
you consistently is one of two things
either he has always been a cheat and
you knew and you decided to get married
to him which is entirely your fault
or let's do what women usually do if he
just started cheating out of the blue
and he does it consistently maybe you
should ask yourself why is he cheating
what are you doing wrong because that's
what we always ask when a woman cheats
or what did the man do so maybe you
should ask yourself
I agree yeah I agree with him as well
I'm just putting other points boy okay
what is your question oh I forgot now
that's it oh no finish I'm those type of
people all right if you cut me off again
all right all right yeah but I think a
lot of times as women we just think
we're the hot and I just think we
could use a little bit of humility and
understanding manner manner look it if
what if men left us every time we sought
attention from other men we would be so
goddamn single oh my God in this
generation attention
attention that's what I'm saying because
how did we like to me those are the same
seeking attention from another guy is
the same as getting sex from another
girl okay
well yeah it's not right it's just not
right anyway it's it's and I don't think
that is really get over like how how
often do women go out in provocative
clothes in a relationship how often do
women go out to a club in a relationship
we weren't virgins on our wedding days
my my whole point is men are programmed
to sleep with anything guys have a hard
time turning down easy sex it's probably
not even you it's just the sex was there
or maybe it was you and you know I I
just think it's about the kids so yeah I
would I would stick it out I believe
every man will do that I definitely
believe it regardless even if you think
that you're doing the best thing it's
not something that every woman can
accept but with something mentally is it
easier to do this is how I think about
it wouldn't it be easier to just accept
it
yeah I know I seriously I was thinking
about this wouldn't it be easier to just
accept it might happen
I have a favorite like because otherwise
you're gonna be in his phone checking
where he's doing like what are you gonna
do it would disturb your brain I feel
like you know it's a choice it's a
choice right I feel like within the
first year of a relationship a man is
tempted to cheat just to make sure that
that girl is the girl that he wants to
be with but that's just my mentality of
thinking of the relationship wise
I always feel like it happens within the
first year and if it happens after the
first year yeah there's something wrong
with the woman there's something wrong
within the relationship I think man just
like I just think sometimes when like a
hoe is there and willing the guy's just
like
you know a work trip it's like go ahead
I mean I wouldn't say for Man Cheats
then there's something wrong with a
woman sometimes men cheap is they're
just depressed
yeah I mean some some men cheat because
they just don't feel they don't see any
value
as something as the woman is not giving
she's not because
no question have you ever flirted with
another guy in a relationship while
you're in a relationship
well from when you're saying that put
insert and pictures up is basically
cheat and then I would have to say yeah
yeah
okay and did that did that really have
to do with him
was he doing something wrong
I would have to say yeah because
obviously if I'm seeking attention then
it means I'm not getting attention from
my man okay okay so you did it to like
get back at him I wouldn't I wouldn't
say as I get back but it's something
that We crave as women we need that
attention and we need that if you're in
a relationship it's something that your
man should be giving you anyway and if
he's not giving it do you think you're
gonna seek it else do you think men
should break up with women that do that
yeah yeah but to me that's the
equivalent like you can work out a
picture no no I could work out a picture
but I can't work out her yeah sex with
another man that's a lot right
but here's the thing about women you
can't
I don't know it's always very weird
because if you think about it
if you if your woman is doing something
that is affecting the relationship and
you ask her to stop and she doesn't stop
it immediately I don't think there's
anything to work out how many pictures
you can I think some people been doing
that for since they were like 14 it's
become a habit it's not even like
they're doing it for attention anymore
it's become like a that's how they
functions
yeah it's become something that they've
been doing in all their lives so I think
people just need to heal that's what
I'll say before you get in a
relationship
I think women I think we shouldn't heal
okay yeah no no yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's just no no this is what I think um
women like got into therapy to like
control men
yeah and just tell them yeah and I think
the women will send the men to therapy
to just confuse them now I'm not saying
there's not exceptions I'm sure there's
like maybe it helped you personally
yeah yeah yeah well I'm not again I'm
not talking about you but I think in
general when I hear the word trauma when
I hear the word
um
therapy I'm like red flag what right
because it's women-led I think women are
men really shouldn't get like advice and
like guidance from women but I think
that's your wife or your girlfriend's
job
no I think the women should be guided by
the men I think like that goes back to
the we're equal the women should
basically obey she's getting it yes yes
I think like um because the thing is
that what they would do and this happens
in a lot of Christian like churches is
they infiltrated the the churches in the
early the late 1800s early 1900s and
basically like weaponized scripture and
like rewrote scripture to like go
towards a more egalitarian model that's
why they'll be like submit to each other
all that it's like Rewritten
but you know what I went to ghanos and
gone on holiday and actually find out
all the Ashanti tribe actually the Queen
the King has to go to the queen for
advice so to make sure that the queen is
older than the king and actually they
have to relate it so in our Santa tribe
your wife can't be your queen he has to
be your older sister or your auntie
someone that you can actually take
advice from so I wouldn't say taking do
you think tribes like that like
typically have stood the test of time I
mean across the world typically
where I mean with the habitat and how
their culturally Maneuvers help them I
mean they they've distilled it no no I'm
saying like like do you think it's
common for a female-led societies
it's not a female that's society let's
see the king the king is through the
king I'm talking about advice okay like
if let's say another tribe came to
invade he the king doesn't take advice
from anyone but the queen but the queen
is older than the kings that have lived
longer and I guess they have more
um I don't know what women have special
stuff the women May embody wouldn't be
I think our person the King has like if
there's an invasion the king doesn't he
does not his generosity no no no no
advice he does consult with generals but
to make certain moves the only person
that can that he goes to in private is
the queen so the queen says okay you
know what I think he just goes to to in
private to go and sleep with her brother
there's a sister that's what it's a
sister it's a sister yeah yeah you can't
your wife is no your wife is no Queen if
you are a king
how big is this tribe so I'm trying to
try it but that whole thing
I don't I'm sorry yeah no it's fine it's
fine I just I just know typically tribes
that get wisdom from women haven't stood
the test no they I mean they have the
whole song no no I mean I'm saying in
general
um yeah yeah I understand that but what
I'm trying to say is we've seen women
tear down kingdoms if they were not
smart fair then they won't be able to
manipulate Kings to kill each other if
you go back to Asian days you've got
women actually finesse maneuvering and
literally ruling kingdoms yeah they're
more manipulations and just they're more
likely to wage
over anything bro no no no I'm talking
about you've got people no no men will
kill each other over oh
um I want this piece of land Like a Man
kill each other over anything so when
people bring I'm talking about kingdoms
bro I'm talking about women
men invade kingdoms just to go and steal
iron just still Stone like literally any
that that's not I just think what's not
fair no no I get what you're saying but
what I'm saying is that though but you
can't say you you can't seek advice from
your wife I think if you trust her
that's what you picked her to be your
wife then you should be able to in
Comfort yeah consult with me no one is
saying you shouldn't get at that what I
was saying is like well she said she
said you shouldn't she said you
shouldn't get back from your wife and
I'm saying you picked up to be a wife
for a reason so whatever that reason is
you should be able to go to like listen
I want to run this by quickly what do
you think
I just think of a boss like employee
relationship like you might consult you
but it's still like is your boss you've
really coming to you like that
no but your partner is not it's not
necessarily your employee I don't think
well when you say partner that's an
egalitarian model feminists have like
ruined our language and once you hear it
you cannot hear it because what is
partner like what does that symbolize
partnership what is that what does that
mean punish it doesn't mean you have to
be equal but you're going to be even
look I think that's a big I think
there's a difference between being even
and being equal I I don't think okay all
right I think the men should be superior
and the women are below them I I mean
that could work but they have to be
it has to be even the respects to be
even don't have to be equal for example
like our thing what do you mean what do
you mean okay look at our hands for
example right all our fingers right
they're all different sizes but they're
all
equally respective someone came and said
which finger would you want to lose you
said none but they're not even are they
yeah they all work together they all
work together and that's what I'm trying
to explain you don't have to be equal to
be even you can be you know what I'm
saying that makes sense but so I think I
think relationships where you're keeping
score just don't work and when it's like
we need to be even no but even nothing
what does even mean
in a relationship even a relationship
would be okay for example uh if I go
outside and I'll I'll hunt you know it
was I go out there to hunt okay I'll
come home I I suspect my wife to have
made something cooked something so with
both of okay even tours well do you
wouldn't it then be very uneven today
well I don't know because because like
like for example I mean in 1800 they got
eight kids now they get one point like
four
so I'm not like because isn't that the
one thing we do bear children
but actually not every guy wants kids
I've spoken to some guys who don't
really care about kids you know I feel
like there's some guys who really also
in some different Vibes like okay yeah
you're right I want kids but I know some
guys were like nah bro it's not for me
I'm like well well I think when the
government you know takes your kids from
you and gives them to the woman it's
like a tough yeah but but I'm saying in
general wouldn't it just be like if
we're gonna go off of even
like for example the average man makes
more than the average woman but the
average woman's fatter than the average
man
we're gonna go like it starts with looks
right yeah yeah I mean like if you look
at the severe obesity stats it's like
women are like double
I mean I'm not I'm not justified or
nothing I'm just saying that you know
respect can be evenly shared across but
you don't have to be equal
also um but I think
we've been going at the women really but
the reality is in truth it's not just
the women that have this issue everyone
has the issue men men today don't even
know what they are meant to be doing in
a marriage and that's the fact the truth
is the reason why
um gender roles work is because when a
woman is taking care of the kid building
the home
that should be her primary focus how can
she do that and still be making
decisions for the family it doesn't make
sense that is the role of the man the
man is meant to protect provide and come
with the decision making
leaders yeah but she doesn't have to
decide I'm not saying that no I'm not
going I'm just making a general point at
what is happening in society today so
it's not just the women that have the
problem yeah women obviously don't want
to play their part to a large extent
they're still very good women out there
but to a large extent women are like
trying to be men and men also are trying
to be women so it's like well it plays a
traditional part of it well marriage is
meant to be a traditional one most women
these days yeah but it's just
interesting because when we talk about
like
um women making decisions like this
wasn't even argued about a hundred years
ago that's my point yeah the traditional
part of it marriage is meant to be
traditional majority of women these days
are not traditional
I'm going to read super chats for a
second and then I'm gonna go to the next
one also guys I've been tweeting
where you can submit questions for the
panel on Twitter so make sure you follow
my I say I always put the title of the
show so make sure you follow my Twitter
or super chats okay Dr David Baker
um according to knop 2017 of men who
cheat 56 or one-time cheaters 28.5
percent cheat twice and 15 are serial
cheaters most times it can't it can be
worked out that's the other thing I was
thinking about it if only 15 of men are
serial cheaters like I literally was
thinking about this why has every woman
dated a Serial cheater
we almost search for it yeah yeah
something where they may have cheated
once and then they they build up
something in their mind that every time
they go out they're cheating
but they don't actually know for a fact
yeah that's true we make up stories yeah
it's like for whatever easily for what I
think that's my social media messes us
up so much like I don't think we're
meant to deal with that like many
problems like I think that's why we get
like the abuse like that's always what
women say like all yeah because it's
just like in our ear all the time okay
um Horace Davis uh cheating means
breaking rules to achieve a goal a woody
a woman's body changes for a man where a
man is the same or better with many sex
partners righteous polygamy polygamy is
a cure in this Society c matherson um
these women need to get used to sharing
a man because to be honest most average
men won't have anything to do with them
FS Claire men shouldn't try to lead they
will listen to what they feel like fight
you when they don't and undermine you
for not leading the way they would let
them uh spend their life looking for the
one
um
that guy sounds like and anyway
[Music]
I'll say it go say it like an idiot
bro horse Davis I'm the Devil is a
feminist why didn't the serpent talk to
Adam C matherson
um shy Roney in the house
um boundless Guardian no real men are
going to put their hand on women full
stop there's no good reason for a man to
hit a woman regardless of what she says
or does men and women are different we
can't hold them till the same standard I
would agree
if if I would actually a hundred percent
agree with that if we admitted that men
and women are not equal and men are
superior but I think as long as the laws
and Society are treating us as equals
it's equal rights equal lefts that's my
opinion on it little Uzi um women will
cry about abuse or women will cry about
men abusing women but won't go to the
police but will go online and tell
everybody else to make them handle it
just to find out she's lying in the end
she's getting shot or destroying the
man's life a map butcher guys go ahead
and bust your ass to provide and see it
Go unappreciated the more you ask the
more you provide the more they want it
never ends ask me how I know Matt
butcher guys go ahead and bust your ass
to bro you said the same thing twice
um FS Claire interrogation questions are
great until she gets mad then your
vulnerability will be thrown in your
face and used to insult you don't do it
Dr David Baker math time uh 23.5 percent
of divorces include include a claim of
abuse 50 percent of domestic violence is
non-reciprocal 70 is female 45 of the
divorce rate is 45
um a maximum of 1.6 of men are one-way
abusers that includes the expanded
definition and false claims C Matheson
it's not it is entirely not okay that
most women are not virgins FS Claire
this is why we are walking away we are
afraid of women but we must protect
ourselves from accusations when she is
mad and our lives are destroyed if they
could be crushed by an accusation alone
what would they do
um
see Matheson Pearl asked the women how
much more they expect men to take in the
age of promiscuity
um for 45 or 42 46 and 2 Kanye has to
pay billionaire Kim Kardashian 200k a
month in child support a man's careers
for family a woman's career is for
herself and to remain independent Matt
butcher thank you for putting male and
female relationships back on track that
the rest of nature follows Intuit
intuitively don't f with Mother Nature
you will lose keep working on your
reading skills Pearl see Mathers and
your personalities are not attractive
those women want us to settle for
nothing I'm tondal are you Sam hype
girlfriend C matherson they expect us to
be okay with an old ran through
overweight Street woman math is in
quality women are one percent quality
men are 80 C math or send women expect
traditional men like our grandfathers
while giving us Lena the plug results
um uh Therese kind modern women bring
other men's kids enter black dragon my
21 year old brings peace sex loyal oh I
read that one yesterday that's from
yesterday uh Let me refresh it real
quick guys
also make sure you're liking the video
guys a like is free that is the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out these streams uh bro Horace
Davis Pearl your thought process is sexy
J um thank you
jmd 749 tell the guy in the baby blue
hat that the thumb is King you cannot
hide any tools and do anything without
it stop simping dude oh wow
look it they roast everyone it's not
all right question yes or no do men like
old women typically no no no wow really
everyone admits this yeah all right yes
or no do men like typically
partially
what yes yeah oh they do explain
well you know I make a very good living
from a lot of men who do seem to really
enjoy what I offer she has a fair point
do men like typically yeah yeah
two men like horse I don't think so no
okay they like them but they won't wipe
them no no no
partially parsley what do you they like
to screw them yeah do they like that
they enjoy them for their own benefit
wow this is an honest panel usually
everyone's like no
I'll be in denial
um okay so gonna
um when
[Music]
when do you notice a woman's looks start
to fade
30. yeah I don't know I have not I can't
I couldn't even I need an age from you
for E5 45 and before that you don't
notice any aging
nah listen if you see my auntie you
whoa she is you wouldn't even believe
this is some people that just you know
that don't crack but anyway okay what
about for white women
[Laughter]
I'm 26. 26 yeah I would have thought you
was older um
so now I can't comment
um okay so 25 for white women 45 for
black women maybe just my auntie I don't
think I'm gonna make it there all right
all right go ahead I have no idea add 30
35 30 35 yeah I would have said between
25 and 30. 25 and 30. okay
um I'll say maybe 30 to 35.
sorry what was the question when do you
first notice a woman starts to age I
think it depends on the woman
I I remember remember just in general
the average tick but if you're a woman
and you don't take care of your body and
you don't eat good food and you go
through drinking and all kind of thing
you're not gonna look good but then you
could be an older woman and you eat good
food you use good cream you have no
stress you're blessed and still look
good yes I've seen some women and
they're younger than public some of my
peers or Etc and the old like sometimes
I see 20 year olds yeah and they look
like they're 40 50.
okay okay
what age do women generally start to
look older
do you notice a woman's looks begin to
fade in general I would say about 45
Plus
45 plus okay this is delusional well
come on 45 black women don't generally
age yes you guys do like it's slower but
you could well I I was never confused my
45 year old with a 25 year old in my
life in my five year old Caucasian
against a 45 year old black woman more
time so you're gonna put them out oh no
this is delusion
no that's serious no remember that logic
is yours it's not it's not allergic it's
what I see in my eyes it's logic it's
still I'm not bruh the problem with that
logic is you're comparing two different
women that particular woman does she
look younger at 45 or when she herself
was 25 that's the question oh that's an
obvious question in itself exactly so
that means there's a point where she
starts to age it doesn't matter if
relative to other women is different
I don't know how I don't know boy all I
know is I thought that you was 35 or
something you just said 26 yeah I I I
thought 40 you know
go go ahead uh I would say
you'll start to see it through the
health and I would Advocate and let men
know because it's towards the men
um you will start to see a woman's looks
start to Decay from their eyebrows
yes really I feel like it's their hands
I think it's their eyebrows but it's
like saying when you know a man's age
has changed because of their hairline
oh wow well now they got the hair
transplants what I think is by the knees
I think you can tell a woman's age by
their knees
really I always feel you can kind of see
it in their hands
too can you um elaborate on that and use
the knees here as an example because I
was she's the oldest and the knees look
really young
yeah go ahead what do you what do you
again you see that you see what I'm
saying so
[Laughter]
huh
no it's like um she has a fair point she
said just bring your office sorry
more
[Laughter]
it's kind of dismissed I'm sorry what's
up my hands are like a 400 year old
corpse there if that helps
why do you think it's so hard in general
you guys have been a good panel but in
general for women to admit that aging
happens and that men are less interested
in them the older they get like why is
there always a cope
no what you're saying is choose still
and like that goes back to one of your
earlier points in terms of um
childbearing being able to give more
kids etc etc so on that respective yeah
I 100 percent agree with you and yes
obviously as a woman gets older her
looks becomes more depreciated yeah and
so yeah you are very right but again if
you age like like fine wine then again
is aging like fine wine everyone's fat
yes you are your bmi's overweight I
guarantee we could do a scale right
there probably look at the Caribbean and
no I'm saying that and I'm not even
trying to be like rude it's just like
like objectively even like we could do
BMI going back into the age and we could
meet was desirable no it wasn't like
this is such a I think it's men now men
have adapted to the market I'm not even
saying like I would be the picture
perfect skinny chick but I'm saying
overall we don't age as well as they did
50 years ago 100 years ago the food
wasn't as messed up we exercised more
weren't sitting at an office all day
Caribbean if you're skinny yeah or your
marker it's not desirable what in the
Caribbean people that are skinny it's
like a Maga what would I would say in
Jamaica don't tell you you need to eat
food it's not desirable the Caribbean
men like meet on their bones why why is
it when any ethnicity if man gets money
and is very attractive he picks a thin
woman with a butt and boob she'll still
have butt and boobs
what because he wants the Fraternal is
that genuinely what you think you think
okay
okay wait so let me get this straight
this is what you think you think that
rich men that are attractive from all
Races pick thin women
so they can get them fatter
that's what you think well a skinny
woman just looks more ideal and are many
like when you don't care about it's not
something okay so so you've got my
skinny looking okay let me let me get
this straight so you think that they
pick these women
so they can post them on Instagram not
because they prefer those women
well I can't speak for a minute no no
I'm talking about it but what I've heard
what men say yeah
a lot of marriages have just been traps
that were set for the men in reality
that's that's the
that's we all know a lot of women trap
men and get them to marry them so I just
know that you're just saying that to
shut down her point it's the reality how
many how many relationships start from
the world
if a man gets trapped into her marriage
if you're a man yeah how are you gonna
make a girl lock you down and trap you
into a marriage anyway are you injured
even even most men are average guys most
men well just dance the average Garden
yes most men don't have the way without
to understand the full nature of women
and that's why the Western world is
actually in the state it is today
all right the most desirable men you
know pick fat women
yeah okay they pick fatter women over
thinner women yeah
yeah Time and Time and Time right now
everyone that I see that wiped off yeah
with a ring on the fluffy man
I'm not gonna lie
yeah
if they're picking if they're picking
fat women it's because all the women
there are fat
it's not because they prefer it yeah
so beauty is objective like all the
subjectivity it's just not true thinner
women get more swipes on dating apps
they've had the men rank thinner versus
bigger women yeah then you go oh Beast
yeah where everything's hanging down
like but it's hanging over your front
and all that yeah all right that's the
next level yeah but obviously I wouldn't
even like I'm not trying to discriminate
against any any kind of weight because
there's somebody for somebody what a man
it's man don't like what one man's
rubbish is
so what I'm not gonna say uh like oh
because she's big that she can't get
married all right yeah I didn't say she
can't I didn't say she can't get married
you know what beauty is
all right what what woman in the media
do men desire that's overweight I'm not
leaving anymore what woman do men desire
that's overweight in the media no I'm
not saying that men will men will say
all right then yeah there ain't gonna be
no size eight to ten God that I'm I'm
most men are going for they're between
14 I would say like 12 and 14 curvy I
don't know no I'm a nice beauty that
wants a wife a girl full of bone
I didn't say bone but I think women or I
think men prefer thinner women yeah slim
yeah uh okay and and 14 to 16 is
generally overweight in general no she
said 12 to 14. okay are you happy 12 to
14.
because you can be you know what I'm
bought a bigger waste you know I'm like
so it comes across as a bigger woman but
she's actually not that big her belly
can be small the reality is they would
never ask men what men want the thing is
most men
cannot say what they want because of how
women lash out so most men would settle
and just deal with what they can get
because most men actually don't have a
choice that is what we're saying is when
you look at the men that have the most
Choice what do they go for I feel like
it's the men who have the choice I'm not
ready as a woman I feel like it's the
man who picks the woman not the woman
exactly no
what is the number one way people are
meeting under 30.
well I don't agree with part internet
yet but is that what you agree with I'm
asking what is the number one way people
are meeting dating upper internet okay
what percent of the time do women swipe
right yeah
what percent of the time do you think
women swipe right I don't think they do
much I've never ever seen so women women
swipe right five percent of the time and
how much do you mean uh around 50 so
it's the men who's treating the women
right now it's the women choosing the
men how when we're swiping right five
percent of the time and the men are
swiping right 50 that means we're far
more picky than the men it also means
that we're all sharing then why do you
think women have dated cheaters because
it's a small percentage of men that
we're all going after
so again his point is that when you look
at the men with the most choice they
don't pick fat women they don't pick
size 14s
they pick thin women with butt and boobs
I think this shouldn't even be
controversial so the facts in the right
places yeah
basically a healthy BMI typically
um
do you disagree with this well if you're
gonna go back to like some of the
earlier points is in chemistry
psychology
Etc then yeah because a man's going to
be looking at her child bearing Apes if
the apes are bearing enough or the
overbearing or underbearing I don't know
but I'm not a guy so I can't really say
about that because I don't look at girls
in it so I don't really know but but I'm
saying you you can you can kind of see
like the same way the the most beautiful
women in society who do they pick
no
all right when we look at models right
the most beautiful women in society
eight to tens when they're they're
beautiful right who do they tend to pick
yeah
handsome men right yeah so when men have
the most money they're gonna say many
they're they're no they don't care about
They Don't Care About The Money They
Don't Care About The Money Slim looking
girls correct so what does that tell us
that men like wait come on what slim
girls thank you
that well not every man though still we
we know not every man but most men when
given the choice will pick Slimmer women
would you say that's true I think down
to Geographics yeah I agree with that
though Geographics because if you're
coming from a western Society here right
like say Europe then you're gonna go for
the girl that's on the Bony side and but
then if you're coming from the Caribbean
you're going for it
they typically still if you look at work
if you typically find what look at what
men find attractive they take dating
apps from all over the world
it's typically the waist to hip ratio
you know what I think Men actually like
women based on the your first encounter
of the top woman who saw growing up for
example up guys guys were born and
brought up in the west they like light
skin girls whatever they they think
that's attractive because that's what
it's all growing up go to Ghana there's
some men who like big women because
that's what I saw growing up I think
that's how the human brain is formed
when you when you're a guy because I
what she said I could understand because
I got uncles what was successful but
they're like women with meat that's what
that's what they like right do they do
they typically no no no no no no no
more time when they marry those women
those women were slim they became fat in
the marriage
look at all your aunties gonna look at
their pictures
why are you lying
it's like this is like like come on
I've definitely got to be sincere with
myself yeah and me being sincere I can't
say oh what should sound isn't true I
get where you're coming from but that's
the worst like she said that's based on
where are you from because the people
who are born in Chicago Nigeria wherever
they might have been to other things
they might like well Nigeria yeah yeah
but that's what you're saying that they
they were Slimmer but not the bigger I'm
coming from me seeing them now but I'm
what I'm saying is men typically pick
slim women is that true or not true yes
well I'm saying is based on where they
are as well I would say men typically
pick Slimmer women they might have a big
butt yeah okay yeah but the waist is
yeah yeah yeah right I agree yeah I
agree not Caribbean men boy they love
you yeah
with that big belly anyway no but yeah
hey I got a big belly no but I mean like
one that's hanging up like no but I mean
ladies ladies ladies I think we need to
give men a bit more credit it's not
again body shame anybody hold on one
second please it's not even just about
the sex thing it's like a lot of times
we forget the biological implications of
some of these things
men naturally want a healthy woman if
they care about building a legacy can
you can you look up so it's not just
when you when you see women that are
overweight it it is an indicator of
something wrong with their health that's
the reality and any man with any sort of
intelligence who has worked on himself
and wants to build a future for himself
is not going to set out to pick a woman
who is already showing signs of poor
health because one she's more than
likely to pass that down to her kids
if a woman can't even figure out how to
feed herself and make herself look
healthy what do you think she's going to
feed the kids
I'm also looking up I'm also looking up
the famous Caribbean man and and it's
like we got Shaggy's wife Finn no you're
hungry we got we got it
I'm taking look at I'm taking his his
point it's different and I'm looking up
Doug E fresh wife
what doggy fresh yeah he's from New York
who even is that I just Googled
Caribbean man yeah
this is what I'm looking up this is the
top ones that come up all right now
you're going too far
what testing this wait are we talking
about celebrity people yeah I'm talking
about it I'm talking about the men with
the most options who has the most
options the celebrity okay celebrities
you know you know they do like uh you're
telling who's got more options than
Drake future all of these I know she
doesn't love them BBWs
[Music]
the environment is providing them that's
what they see that's what they encounter
if they have no other choice but then it
goes back to when they have the choice
what do they pick
um big bum pretty face and what
what did we say in the beginning of the
conversation that we're talking about
what
what do we say in the beginning of the
conversation we're talking about I lost
it from in in general remember we are
talking in general there's exceptions
but we're talking in general
oh yeah yeah okay okay thank you
um I'm gonna Read Super chats really
quick also guys make sure you like the
video
um
all right Damon barcel I'm uh Puerto
Rican I can definitely tell you we don't
pick overweight women over skinny please
stop capping
um Watchmen are they prepared to give
their lives for their significant other
then why can't you either follow their
Authority or disconnect with social
media uh women age like beef Mason
everybody built like Humpty Dumpty or
the Michelin Man now
bro Davis women age like cheese um The
Haven project
by and large modern women can't even
Define what a woman is ask the panel
what does the wife see if you get an
answer we did that question already it
probably came late
um okay would you guys accept would you
guys try to work through cheating
I think I'd be all right with cheating
honestly as long as I could film it for
only fans if you could do it probably
that'd be fine man or woman I wouldn't
mind okay go ahead if you asked me this
about
five years ago I would have said no now
I would be
I'd have to think about something I
couldn't make that dramatic no okay
you'd think about working through it I'd
think about it if it was like yeah if it
was the first time I'd have to think
about that I can't like just it depends
as well of how long we're in the
relationship or what we've got going on
if it's something early then I don't
think he's taken me serious really I
think it's just a play play thing oh I
wouldn't why what changed from five
years ago to now I was young mentally I
wasn't thinking I was thinking oh I'm
the only one that you have to yeah it's
all about I wasn't looking into a man I
didn't know what a man is I didn't know
what men
had to offer I didn't know I was really
young okay so my mentality was different
not saying you know there's so much
about there's so much around it there is
so much around it and I can't just sit
here and rant on about it forever but I
do know that back then I would have been
that no but I think it's because I
experienced it when I was younger and it
put me in a very dark place I was very
like guard up if you cheat on me I swear
we're never I'm never gonna deal with it
it's stressful yeah like being on their
phone all the time trying to figure out
what they're doing no no
no what do you mean though like I I just
find that like like if you're worried
about cheating all the time it's
stressful
oh I don't I don't know about no I don't
know I feel like going into a
relationship without thinking about
cheating is a bit more of a healthier if
you're there thinking about it then you
shouldn't be in a relationship you're
not ready yeah you need to heal yeah the
healing yes love healing what he said
the healing
what about you cheating yes we can talk
through it okay
yeah I've already said yeah from earlier
I don't feel like that's a deal breaker
within marriage I feel like something
that you can work out as a couple okay
if it's um sexual then no I mean like
picture posting whatever but I feel like
it's been to have sex cheat in a
marriage than it is
going to sound so bad but it is very
different yeah
someone said actually I'll read this
later God
um
yeah I think it's something that you can
work through
have you ever worked through it yes I
have okay do you feel like were you able
to let it go or did you still bring it
up
um
I feel like if a guy's making you feel
like inferior
to that of a woman
or makes you feel like like no
self-worth and stuff then that's really
wrong but then like if it does it in a
way where
it kind of just keeps that like teams
like to himself like oh no like
I don't know like when it starts to
wreck the home or say the woman becomes
a home wrecker that woman that is like
flirting with or whatever and she starts
phoning you and abusing you and sort of
like causing disruptions to the home
then I feel that that's like really
really wrong but then on the other hand
um
if it was a flinging Napper then you'd
be like right it's never going to see
that person again
still won't really be happy about it no
no no happy that yeah
I wouldn't be happy about it but
however
um
I don't know I think there's levels man
there's definitely levels to it there's
definitely levels
well I've come to the understanding when
it comes to cheating and when the Mel is
cheating anyway is that there's a reason
why the male has cheated and it's most
likely because the female is lacking
something within that relation so it can
be worked upon if
they have that conversation or
communicate that and she kind of fixes
what she's lacking if she can't fix what
she's lacking then continue
you know he's going to continue to cheat
and obviously that female is going to
feel her I won't kiss me be so
would I work on it
if I was lacking something I would if I
wasn't lacking anything and he was
cheating for the sake of cheating then
no I will not work on it you think
you're ever lacking nothing
it's very personal I'm not going to get
drawn up for this but I consider myself
as a high quality woman
so compared to a lot of females that's
out there I would see myself as high
quality currently today
right but I said lacking nothing
the things that I lack wouldn't
um
wouldn't be so much of a big deal to
amount okay what do you lack I'm a lion
[Laughter]
go and cheat that you're annoying
you think so 100 percent
what when you can get someone that's
just gonna say oh yeah you're the best
man in the world and then he comes on to
you and you're just being annoying like
um okay well your siblings can be
annoying but you're not going to hate
them for it or you're not going to now
say that yeah he doesn't hate you
because he cheated he just wanted to put
his dick somewhere else
like why are you telling him why like
that is annoying
it's funny it's like we don't listen to
what the men saying
my annoying I don't mean annoying in the
times where you would hate me obviously
you wouldn't be with me in the first
place but I'm annoying in the sense
where you know
like how your siblings with your name
but you still love them at the same time
yeah but we know that men don't
everyone's annoying to a certain degree
there's some aspects of all of us that
will you know that's annoying but my
whole point was you don't think there's
any areas you could improve it
and you said well I'm annoying but that
wouldn't make him cheat she did say she
was going to get drawn out right now oh
yeah I mean you can say it but okay I
would say oh please save me do you know
what like some men can have dedicate
their cherry and icing and still cheat
like you can be the perfect wife you do
everything yeah and it's still just
they're just them guys that just like
going out like what does a guy called
lacking in a woman it's like
in femininity because part of femininity
is humility
well you just said that menu regardless
you said it's not nature too man I said
no no I said men want to cheat
regardless but only the top 15.
I said no I said no no no no I said go
into the marriage assuming it may happen
and try to work through it but a very
small percentage of men can't cheat yes
so so we go back to women pick men that
cheat yeah but it's in our biological
system to want to reproduce it they're
right there's more chances for men to
cheat without it being any fault on the
woman but still there's no more chance
no no I'm just saying it but you're
saying that it's just how that comes
with a male makeup that's how we are no
I think about it like this the average
man can't get women easily so for a man
to actively go out and look for a woman
to cheat with when he can't really even
attract women means that there is
actually something wrong sex workers
there's some paying go sleep a woman is
that not cheating
my point is for a man to actively go out
look the man that doesn't normally get
women for him to actually leave his
woman who is meant to be obviously but
it's in our makeup like you're saying
bro you say this in our makeup most men
can't most men don't even get sex
some Can't Get Enough
okay but you know what not not to say
you're right or wrong but I wrote this
book by a guy who was a pimp in New
Orleans and he describes how he became a
pimp there's no any woman could change
him because that's how he just saw his
environment how his mom was right so if
that's his makeup it doesn't matter what
kind of woman he's got but the whole
point is most men don't even get the
opportunity to do that like it's only 15
20 of men that can really cheat like
that one out of three men are either
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year
a woman if he desires to want to have
sex I disagree with that any man can
actually have sex with a woman he will
find sex it's just a type of quality a
woman he's not like that that's the
difference
that's not true I'm telling you if you I
went to I went to like a pickup artist
conference once
and this is where like men pay thousands
of dollars to know how to get late to
learn how to get late
no but that's the whole point there's
there's one out of three men that are
very very lonely that I don't that are
that are very unattractive that like
most women I I think would be very hard
to get a woman to sleep with I don't
think it says I've seen a real life
experience okay what's your what's your
real life experience so when I was uh
very young I was working at Domino's and
um as a delivery driver so I went to go
and do a delivery and I saw two people
having sex in front of my car on the
Bonnet what
yeah but um those two people were
obviously homeless
um and the woman was doing it to to get
some money and the man was just
penetrating her in front of my car so a
guy can have sex if he wants to have sex
oh you're talking about it you're
talking about hookers
yeah she's a human she's just a low
quality woman right but I I think my
point is you know women find 80 percent
of men is ugly not okay not decent we
think 80 of men are ugly really yes it
must be and they've done this in person
they've done this on dating apps
I don't think that's about females
opening up their legs as different
reasons what do you mean there's
different reasons there's different
reasons why females open up their legs
and we've seen that in real time females
open up with their legs in an emotional
state and that emotional state can also
be financially but we have to look at
the data and the data is that we swipe
right five percent of the time on dating
apps
100 of women want 20 of men we discount
80 amount there's one out of three men
that are virgins so that's telling us
that less and less men are having sex
but more women are having sex with a
smaller percentage of men they choose
not to if they wanted to they can have
sex or just with a low caliber woman
well no they'd have to pay for it yeah
but it's still cheap but no my whole
point is there's very few men that act
like that have women coming out to them
to the point they could cheat a lot like
that's why they could they could pay for
sex but I'm saying most men don't have
women approaching them like that
like and if you look at the data it's
like we rate 80 percent of men is ugly I
will count you but typically I'll
counter hold on
men can pay for sex and females can't
count on your plan there are no brothels
for females none I mean the brothel is
just outside say I want sex
for men so that will show you within
itself again I didn't say that man I
didn't say men couldn't pay for sex but
any any man can pay for it but a lot of
men don't want to do that
so it's a choice
I mean you could say my my whole point
is that most men cannot cheat like that
most men do not most most men do not
have women throwing themselves at them
like that they do they just choose not
to want to accept they choose not to pay
for it yeah right but but my whole point
is most men are not going to cheat on
you like that because they don't have
women coming at you all about them all
the time I'm not even when they choose
not to pay for it how many men can
afford to pay for sex right you guys are
acting like a little like most men have
money that's why they ain't having sex
because they ain't going on dates and
they don't want to pay for it
like most men most men can't even have
if okay sex okay we can pay for sex how
many men can actually afford to pay for
sex really like on a regular basis to
the extent to the point that we need sex
how many men can pay for it on a regular
basis that was sacrifice that was
sacrifice
so my whole point is you're speaking on
something you don't even know I mean
it depends
but that's my whole point you don't even
know we're all speaking on things
but his whole point is that they can't
afford sex that's not true and if they
can't afford this the average no it is
true I mean there's more unemployed men
than there's been in a really long time
the average man makes 35
000 pounds uh um in England they spend
over a third of their income on Route we
have talked about inflation and you're
acting like they have this discretionary
income we're living in the UK let's just
be real everyone has money even if
you're on benefits you're getting 250 a
month you have money you will sacrifice
50 pounds a month to go and get that
vagina you might not cannot can't afford
it but you will suck if you've got money
there you will sacrifice someone are a
bit funny with that I feel like I've
been misconcepted then and it was like
differently yeah I thought guys like got
all the pic of everything like so like
just hearing those facts that needs to
me it's something I'm gonna have to go
away from here and go do a bit more
research on but in my era growing up
yeah like even like you talk from your
grandmother and your mother like it's
the boys that come to you you don't go
to the boys kind of thing so
traditionally
um it's for the guy to come and ask you
for a day etc etc so I don't really know
about old females going tomorrow going
oh do you want to go out on a date oh do
you want to take me out oh I like you no
but I want to marry you but I'm sorry
the number the number one way we're
meeting is dating apps I don't know
anything about that I don't either but
I'm not talking about you I'm talking
about the data under 30. over 30 it's
different but
you see all of that for me right for my
generation that weren't really a thing
and personally myself right I think
that's something that is Americanized
right
it's here now it's here it's here now
but he went here like 25 years ago 30
years ago that weren't how it was you
know what I mean but differently now
like from what I've seen when it just
like not even really come here but just
about came here I watched that serial um
killer shows and stuff like that from
America and I just thought oh guys that
go on dating app so like serial killers
like it could be someone else's picture
and then like trying to meet you and all
that kind of stuff so for me that
probably wouldn't be well the reason the
reason there's a whole group of men that
women don't see it's like four is five
sixes and sevens are sleeping with
eights nines and tens
so that's why that's why like we think
we're hotter than we are we think we
deserve more than we do
because we find 80 of men is ugly
so it's a small percentage of men screw
in all the chicks
yeah because I've got Dr um what do you
say the um the one of the Beast
yes so that's why I say the average
chick gets to pick the the small
percentage of men get to pick but the
other men are just taking what they can
get
oh wow and historically only 40 percent
of men have reproduced ever so your your
theory is still wrong because if if most
men have been having sex that number
will be higher
because it's only in recent times we've
had contraceptives so if most men have
been having sex in the past there will
have been more men that will have
reproduced so what what were they doing
most men in the past
they would go to war they would die that
he was was back then it was only the
strongest the richest men that could
reproduce because other like you how how
else would you get a woman you can't
can I ask a question then
can you elaborate or clarify where are
these hoes coming from
if that's the case what's a hell and
sleeps around
okay they sleep with the same men how
many women has
I'm gonna use Kanye instead of Drake how
many how many women has Kanye slept with
I would have to ask him directly yes
probably over uh sorry Kanye but
probably over 100. okay so there's a
hundred women there
okay same with Drake same with all these
celebrities I've heard guys say body
count like there's um I think Will
Chamberlain didn't he say he slept with
10 000 women wow
where did you find the time
all those energies I think he got AIDS
or something I won't even lie to you I
mean like Magic Johnson so if we also do
the maps and weigh out how many females
are in this world and how much men are
in this world and how much hose we have
currently today
The Mask doesn't really add up how does
it not add up it doesn't because where's
this calculator as well that says all
these numbers and stuff well okay I'll
ask you what do you think the average
body count is today
average number 20 20. what do you think
the average body God knows honestly I
don't for a girl average girl don't know
please no no I need a number I need to
guess
okay okay average to the average bride
is 31. so 31 year old what's your guess
[Music]
don't no man sorry sometimes you just I
don't think about these type of things
right I don't really think about it okay
you've never slept with anybody no I'm
saying overall in general I can't really
you know what is the average I don't
even know how many people
your friend group how many your friend
group my friendship group yeah how many
yeah average body count in your
friendship group I don't have friends
friend
thank you average body count let's just
say uh nine or a number nine all right
average body count
five six okay
um I would say 10 to 15. okay yeah I was
at 12 12 okay
I'd say between 10 and 15. okay
I see these numbers are so unrealistic
um
based on what I see today base I see the
climate of how females are behaving and
the decisions that they're making that
their mothers now with single mothers
baby mothers in that sense
I would say
their body counts are higher than their
age fats
that's crazy
every age from the moment they start the
problem when they break 10 and pass
their age it doesn't come I mean a lot
of women just lying
yeah they are so so like the whole the
whole point is
by historical point of view 96 of women
would be hoarse because if you weren't a
virgin on your wedding day you were a
you're a concubine you weren't
worthy of marriage so even the low body
counts are considered if we go at
a historical standpoint
yeah because men are now compromising
with the Virgin correct they didn't
really want virgins anymore they're just
compromise well they adapt to the market
they want thin women but they adapt
because like there's research that shows
that men have a need for sex that's not
a want it's a need so when all they have
is fat hoes it's like they take one
[Laughter]
roughly like five to eight Partners like
his like from that's a yeah no no
I'm saying I'm saying where where the
data drops below like like a 20 chance
of a happy marriage 25 I can't remember
off the top of my head but it's like
five to eight over ten it's like you're
done so a hoe means you're just done out
here how is multiple men okay uh so so
I'm saying like I mean in modern times I
I would say
that I mean in modern times I goddamn
they'll accept anything under like 10
but like from a historical point of view
most women would be disqualified for
marriage if they've slept with more than
one person okay so Free People is a hoe
as well it depends who you ask because
it depends oh waffle that word depends
no it is true it depends it really does
I I would say if you ask most men today
it's over 10. that's like the most
common answer I get in 2023
um but I see who they date and I would
say they accept like 15 to 20 if I'm
being honest
um I I would also say from a historical
point of view it's two so if you took
the last a thousand years it's two
um yeah that's and I would say the data
says you're pretty much gonna have a
hard time staying married if you slept
with more than like five to eight people
roughly
so it depends how you interpret it all
those energies in your system
how does your vagina
the divorce rate that we have in yeah
generation because yeah it's Hardbody
count and high depository well yeah and
social media I think didn't help either
yeah marooned everyone yeah yeah maybe
the the younger generation I think
social media is great they exposes
people people are learn to expose
themselves usually a better option to
choose the naive one will get affected
by it though you know
a lot a lot changed in society because
when I went to school
and have the Bible lessons and stuff
like that you know what I mean and we
had to go to Sunday school whereas now
we we don't we don't have to do that and
then like there's like what 52 gendered
I never heard of it until today now um
and I'm not being biased against anybody
be what you want to be but
well you know like obviously I could say
a lot but you know in society today as
it says you're persecuted speaking the
truth so if I was to speak my real truth
what I really want to say then I'll have
a lot of people come for me but I think
it's been like this though if we go back
into history anyone has spoke the truth
got killed it's not me I don't think I
think everything this has been happening
yeah I think oh it's in the first
highlighter yeah it's an offense to say
certain things you cannot say it
publicly
what time period
there was no figures different time
periods had different you know I mean we
come from there is no such thing as free
speech what we come from like medieval
where people get in your skin literally
skin off them because they said
something it's just I think Human Nature
has been the same like I said before I
feel like right now we get to see it
directly it's direct consuming you know
like right now we can see oh wow Kim
Kardashian's doing this to Kanye without
oh wow Kim Kardashian is with my God
you still see things in front of your
eyes
that's the thing I think you still see
it I'm sure when I was going I don't
know who your neighbors dating right we
couldn't even watch someone kiss on the
TV we had to go under the table
underneath the tablecloth let's turn our
heads we weren't allowed to see it in
fact growing up just half of the stuff
we see on TV now you just never saw it
sure I agree you did not see it we have
been exposed media and TV and government
are exposing our children yeah but yes
they are right there's just some things
back them days yeah you you just wasn't
nothing and it's crazy in the schools
they're like putting the multiple
genders have you seen some of the like
sex ad they're giving the kids it's so
totally wrong I mean like yeah when
you're at like three and four you don't
even know if you're a boy or a girl
you're not you're not taught to see sex
you know I mean like sex is something to
eat I think you tend to more grasp when
you're about like 12 13 then you start
to realize oh that's a boy that's a girl
kind of thing but I feel like
kindergarten primary school that should
even be in school like
what's the legal age for sex isn't it 16
it's when they should start yeah exactly
so if it's not legal to have sex until
you're 16 why are you teaching them sex
before 16
right really
I I know I've seen ones where they teach
them what anal sex is I'm like why the
hell do they need to know they put it in
the kids like yeah that would not be my
child learning at school no way they do
it I think it was in Ireland because
they're like slightly more Progressive
than here I think when you get more like
teenager sexually active you know like
when your body starts telling your boy
girl kind of things yeah I think I think
that's all the parents I think I would
kill anybody that talked to my kid about
that yeah yeah I totally agree I just
feel like that's not school or
government's Jewish children I think
that that's just way out of your remit
and what are those what's a predator
gonna do
I think that's a perfect way like that
to to penetrate their mind and think
it's okay yeah yeah well I mean like if
you're a predator what job would you
take the one where you teach kids about
sex like I think very like you could put
your kid in a really bad position by
having a job but now you've put ideas in
their heads yeah because now you've
given them the idea so therefore if you
put an idea in someone's head then
they're going to want to export that bit
more like really that should not be in
schools I feel like you're totally right
in saying that should be down to the
parent
and if say like if if
the children so if the parent says like
because I know when I was at school to
set a letter I'm saying oh is it okay to
teach your child sex education and it
was with Parental Guidance yeah
I I think I think being it that'd be on
my list of bands birth control divorce
abortion
um and sex sad just gone yeah I think
that's true really all of it not all of
it okay I was just wondering no one ever
people are always like no
we should also abandoned DNA test too
right and you know what you've gone too
far
ban DNA testing some men can't check if
the kids are theirs no because that that
benefits to females if you look at the
bigger picture it benefits the females
that's why the females are making
ruthless decisions they don't care okay
wait okay do you think like they should
do paternity testing
why because it's giving females more
freedom more peace of mind to not make
any uh conscious decisions
I kind of get where she's coming
because like you're just not you know
what percent of men do you know what
percent of men that question their kids
paternity or raising a kid that's not
theirs I think yes yes
I think about 60 percent
no not that high not that High Apple
it's quite high today one out of three
wow
and there's some ancestry companies that
are saying like 20 of matter raising
kids that aren't theirs you don't think
they should test it to make sure I feel
like if a guy fools there's doubt
that that child is his I think you
should definitely I think we should just
have it mandatory off the bat and I
think a woman that lies should go to
jail
oh
right yeah they had I don't know about
that one
like you really don't know how or no no
I'm just saying I just I'm just like
like how did they get into that
positions so many to the point where you
don't know who who's yeah
where was their heads
jail
I think if you if you like if you wasted
guys it's crazy because of man I think
it's really a male to do that man a man
can go to jail for not paying child
support but a woman can't go to jail for
lying about paternity yeah well I think
I think if he waste five years he's in
prison lady maybe a lifetime I don't
know yeah yeah I totally agree because
like you're shattering someone's hope
and life and a man who doesn't even know
he's got a you yeah six years old can
you imagine imagine if he thought he
could like I just couldn't have any well
and when you think about it it's got to
be so common because women have types
you know what I mean so it's like even
six foot plus
like when I think of me or I think of my
friends like most people have a type
that they go for so it's like if they
were cheating on someone it would I'd
imagine it would be with their type
so I could see how like the kid could
even look like them and it not be their
kid that's crazy right yeah that's true
yeah
I've heard that men that they they said
in either mice or rats that men that the
women had slept with previously could
influence like what the kid looks like
and they think it might be similar in
women
I don't know this is true okay I don't
know this is true so I'd like to say not
proven not proven just the theory they
have but it's like something with the
genes like if a guy had more like strong
genes that she'd slept with previously
and he like
in her you know that they because if a
guy like in you that you have DNA in you
from him like forever well I've heard of
a woman carry out two tweens from two
different men so yeah pregnant at the
same time when he's like two men's
babies like how soon did you yeah yeah
I've heard of that I think I've seen it
somewhere in the papers two-man sperm
just floating around in you boy mad and
the tea that I've spent the egg yep at
the same time
you know I bet that chick I heard that
and she said it was like within a day I
bet it was a train
it had to have been a train that's the
only thing that makes sense to me it
does not make sense that it was like a
day later right right like some though
in the morning some in the night though
I I do know yeah no I'm just thinking if
you got pregnant with twins you don't
think it had to have been a train
like like at the same time but doesn't
sperm stay close I think it's five days
yeah I'm not saying it doesn't maybe but
I'm just like what are the odds you were
two different guys kid like it had go to
a lab and check this out
I mean you can yeah I would I
volunteered okay you could ask her I
don't know I don't know if she'd come on
my show but I'll invite her
um okay I'm gonna Read Super chats and
then we're gonna close out the show um
all right see matherson if a man deletes
the woman uh should he get the death
penalty if a man deletes the woman
should yeah I don't see why not
um doc right he's killing her is that me
that's a deletes if a man the woman
if a man self deletes the woman should
he get the death penalty what do you
mean self-delete in what way let me know
I'm just reading the soup
that's what I'm guessing yeah
again they say that most women that get
murdered is because it's like for Um
passion of um what is it passion
something to do with passion and crime I
love yeah that's it I bet you a lot of
women get murdered because they've just
made their baby daddy's lives a living
hell
yeah or it's not his kid
ouch
no no I've been looking after her and
going through all them yeah I say this
because there was a case a couple years
ago where a guy like killed his family
and just because I'm doing the divorce
documentary I start to like recognize
like patterns and basically she said
that he could he he was never going to
see his kids again so she killed him she
killed her now I'm not saying it was
okay like that's wrong but I bet you I
bet you that's more common than we know
where it's like the woman
yeah like but psychologically you're
missing we've been taking away
everything that you yeah and worked and
love for I couldn't yeah yeah well
because especially takes right but yeah
like especially like some of the guys
I've interviewed like words
they work yeah they work for like 20 30
years
and the woman and the woman has um his
kids and she basically takes all of his
money now he's on child support he can't
afford some of them end up homeless they
lose their jobs because they're so
mentally like unstable she takes the
kids and then like a lot of them really
are on the brink of suicide yeah yeah
it's really sad yeah mental health is a
thing um 86 of men have never paid for a
prostitute no dudes who can't get women
easily Don't just run off to prostitutes
in order to cheat no more what are they
talking about buying uh sex the average
men are poor sea Masterson panel is a
really good example that women are just
figuring it out they are now realizing
that men are done this panel is quiet Dr
David Baker the Caribbean has suffered
from an obesity crisis for the last 30
years the average man with limited
options doesn't have a choice to not
date an obese women and to get men laid
like
um and to get and to get laid men cap
like crazy Carlos have you ever used a
BMI calculator see Masterson societal
divorce imminent um Damon I'm Puerto
Rican I can definitely tell you we're
overwhelmingly don't oh wait I read this
one already uh Let me refresh it really
quick just to make sure there's no other
ones
um also guys make sure you like the
video uh the dying 304 spider what are
these usernames
um if men paying for sex it's because
they're either inexperienced or
desperate the reason why men don't pay
for sex is because men's desire to be
desired by women that is why a number a
man's number one wish is a threesome
with females hence why men would rather
not pay
um
oh if a man's self deletes the woman
should get the death penalty
oh that's an interesting question if she
lies about paternity and he kills
himself should she get the death penalty
oh
it's a good question but
um final thoughts that would be a lot to
prove though like I wouldn't say
necessarily no but however if whether
you can gather enough evidence
to prove that that's the reason why he
did it
because that would be a hard case to
fight I mean if he shoots himself the
next day after she she tells us yeah but
equipped to go to bankruptcy
okay so final thoughts good it's been a
really interesting experience thank you
for having me on thank you for coming
give me a lot to think about
um yeah thank you I like the dress by
the way very cute oh God
final thoughts social media oh what on
everything overall yeah you can just any
you know speak your piece on anything
social media that you know the social
media thing is a big impact on a lot of
the world today but um once we leave
this room we're just gonna carry on
living up normal lives on Twitter and
we're just gonna leave all of this in
the past so you know it's not that deep
it's just an opinion everyone's got
their opinions yeah
that's all I have to say
I have nothing so thank you
um yeah it's it's been a good learning
experience it's been good to hear
everybody's opinions on everything
um probably changed my mind on a few
things too
um but yeah thank you for having me
yeah
um
it's been good uh so I've learned
different perspectives and also new
information and bit of how the world to
set up I think I'm quite now you've
actually based on what I'm hearing here
um I would say people need to heal
before they engage in any sort of from
serious relationships
um that means you have to amend your
past triggers was when you're healed it
eased out your triggers you can easily
communicate with other people and also
it gives you more self-love and sort of
value so much worse
oh sorry I'm the last I wanted to think
is anyone watches this I think I said
I said um instructions yeah just if
you're being good I guess you would pay
um Authority as well so yeah
well I really enjoyed the host tonight
and the rest of the guests
um I've had a lot of um food for thought
and a lot of subjects where I need to go
and do a bit more homework and stuff
like that however I feel like with some
of us before that um
we see these problems and for that um if
we like to sort of teach our young ones
from Young how to be wives and how to be
your husbands and stuff like that and I
think a lot can change so I feel there's
a lot to be learned and and I feel that
a lot of us we've come from different
walks and um different experiences in
life so I thought that in some ways we
still have like a lot to give and I feel
that
um yeah it'd be nice to sort of have
some some sort of giving classes where
we're not you know like just teaching
things in a really agreed with what pal
said about you know um one of my biggest
things is about about sex in school and
all that kind of stuff I'm totally
against it I'm fully 100 prepared with
that and um yeah I think a lot should be
done about it not being in our schools
yeah ban it I'm a big fan of banning
things yeah band yeah band oh god well
you've been celebrities for Less
button have that you know yeah Council
culture yeah oh yeah yeah you know like
for Less do you know what I mean so like
if you can ban people for less than that
like something as serious as as you like
talking about young people's futures and
stuff like this is about the future
generation so again yeah I feel a lot
needs to be doing and yeah
well the final thoughts are I understand
everyone sees one majority of people see
social media as a negative thing but I
would say if your smart use it as a tool
to benefit you and to filter out people
that you do not want to associate with
and it's as simple as that
can I just say one more thing sorry in
terms of social media I feel like
everyone always puts out their best best
but no one shows like
you know like the glory bits and and the
things that are like really sort of like
hard that they're working through and
stuff like that no one puts like heart
all the hard things that they're going
through on social media everyone like
dresses up and shows like the best
restaurant the best pool the best this
the best that but 99 of the time people
are not even actually leaving that life
it's just it's just there for social
media to make it look glossy and make it
seem nice it's not reality it's like
it's it's shaping a reality that's not
actually really there
thank you guys all for coming great
panel today
um make sure you guys like the video on
your way out a couple announcements
before we end the show
um the first is that we have a Google
form so sign up for a Google form to be
notified of our events we're thinking of
doing
um
a show with previous show guests where
we actually have people perform because
we've had so many musicians on
um so make sure you sign up to the
Google Forum to be notified when we do
do our events we want to do ones in
London and the us so I think it'll be a
lot of fun
um also we are looking at cities in the
U.S and we're going to be doing content
houses in different cities and we're
also going to be signing content or
we're going to be signing talent in
London so make sure you DM me on
Instagram if you want to be a YouTuber
um just pearly things one follow me on
Twitter to see my freestyle all right
like yeah you're out subscribe to the
channel I'll talk to you next time bye